Hey, well good to see you. I glad to see your moustache is still alive. Still got the moustache. Yeah, what do you guys? You guys the spirit gum keeping that on or is it just? Yeah, what is it with people that have moustaches that they're two halves that they don't they don't like yourself. You can't grow a full moustache across the full lipids. You know who is cursed with that too? Clark Gable. Look him up. Oh boy. Welcome to Smartless.
嘿，很高兴见到你。很高兴看到你的小胡子还在。还有小胡子。对，你们俩怎么弄的？你们是用美生胶把它粘上去的，还是？对，那些留小胡子的人是怎么回事，两边分得很开，他们不喜欢这样吗？你没法在整个嘴唇上方都留满胡子。你知道谁也受此困扰吗？克拉克·盖博。去查查他。天哪。欢迎收听《聪明笨蛋》（SmartLess）。
Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. Smart. So, Will, while you've been out of town, Sean has discovered in Vizeline, and he's just popped it in his head. Why do you need a true podcast, Guy? I have to wear 20 hours a day, and I just had it in before it in before we started this be one of the hours that you don't yeah
聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。聪明。所以，威尔，在你离开镇上的这段时间里，肖恩发现了隐适美（Invisalign），而且他满脑子都在想这个。你为什么需要一个真正的播客，老兄？我一天得戴20个小时，而且就在我们开始之前我刚把它戴上，这应该是你不用戴的小时数之一，对吧。
We get four hours without it. No, it's not to keep it as much as I can but you know much better for who I just I just want to get for the listener I keep that going like crazy. No, they're actually not you're your teeth are totally fine and I think you fall into the trap of sort of vanity, health. Well, I don't know. My teeth, my teeth are going crooked. They're not. Yeah, this one is, oh, they're not. They were always crooked.
我们有四个小时不用戴。不，这不是为了尽量保持，但你知道，这对我来说好得多，我只是想让听众知道我一直在疯狂地戴着它。不，其实不是，你的牙齿完全没问题，我觉得你陷入了一种虚荣健康的陷阱。好吧，我不知道。我的牙齿，我的牙齿开始变歪了。并没有。对，这颗是，哦，并没有。它们一直都是歪的。
And then, why don't you just allow one little flipper, one little fang, like everyone else, has one that'solous Gio. It just be less than perfect. I got this one down there. They are, they're pretty, like, screwy. I just want, I'm just getting older and I want to get ahead of it. Uh huh.
然后，你为什么不就像其他人一样，留一个小门牙、一个小尖牙呢？大家都有一颗不完美的牙齿，这很酷，吉奥。它只是没那么完美而已。我下面有这么一颗。它们确实，挺，呃，别扭的。我只是想，我只是在变老，我想未雨绸缪。嗯哼。
Because they started going crazy. Fun. Hey, what about yesterday? Will, you know, Sean and I were having a meeting with Amanda at a very nice restaurant with a very respectable person you've heard of. I've heard about you. And an old snaggle tooth pops out his head gear at the table into his little dish or you have dish that he keeps in his pocket.
因为它们开始变得疯狂。好玩。嘿，昨天怎么样？威尔，你知道，肖恩和我昨天在一个非常高档的餐厅里和阿曼达开会，同座的还有一位你听说过的非常受人尊敬的人。我听说过你。桌上突然冒出一个老掉牙的家伙，把他的假牙套拿出来放进一个小盘子里，或者说那是他放在口袋里的小盘子。
You can't eat with it on. Abel does the same thing. But why don't you put a bathroom and take that out and say, isn't it heavy? He's got to suck the saliva out of it before it puts it in the tray. And you know, we've got a guest. Yeah, no, I know.
你戴着它没法吃东西。阿贝尔也做同样的事。但你为什么不去洗手间把它拿出来呢，而且说实话，不觉得沉吗？他得先把上面的口水吸干，然后才能把它放进盒子里。你知道的，我们还有个客人。对，不，我知道。
I know. Look, I'm just struggling to get through every day. How do you sound? How is it, how is it, how is your, huh? I had a list. I said Dishon the other day. I said Dishon through every day. How do you sound? How is it, um, I had a list. How's your, huh? I had a list. I said to Sean the other day. I said to Sean, are you getting in to his line because you wanted a list
我知道。听着，我每天都挣扎着度日。你听起来怎么样？怎么样，怎么样，你的，嗯？我刚才口齿不清。我那天对肖恩说。我对肖恩说，每天都……你听起来怎么样？怎么样，嗯，我刚才口齿不清。你的，嗯？我刚才口齿不清。我那天对肖恩说。我对肖恩说，你戴上隐适美是因为你想口齿不清
just in case people didn't know you were gay. What are you? What are you? What are you? Yeah. It's called the gay tray. Um, and I was just in the show.
好让人家不知道你是同性恋吗？你是什么？你是什么？你是什么？对。这就叫同性恋托盘。嗯，我当时在节目里开玩笑。
None of them. Yeah, that's the guy. If you're looking to pull a question mark off your profile, Um, and I was joking this show. Yeah, that's the guy. If you're looking to pull a question mark off your profile, try gay trade. What question mark? Um, gay trade. Well, yeah, I had a little bit of a list before now. It's worth. I'm getting through it. I'm getting through it. OK, well, if you hit a couple of,
没有一个。对，就是那个。如果你想从个人资料里去掉那个问号，嗯，我当时在节目里开玩笑。对，这就是那家伙。如果你想从个人资料里去掉那个问号，试试同性恋托盘。什么问号？嗯，同性恋托盘。好吧，是的，我之前有点口齿不清。现在好了。我在克服它。我在克服它。好吧，如果你遇到几个，
but I did just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have,
但我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，
I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have,
我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，
I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have, I just have Okay. Okay. Gosh, that's so much better. What kind of charge you get? Just one that wasn't, it was on wheels and I'm on a Herbiv floor, so it was like sliding all over the place. Are you okay? Are you okay? You just need a sandbag.
我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，我刚刚，好吧。好吧。天哪，好多了。你弄的是哪种充电器？就是那种没有固定好、带轮子的，而且我踩在地毯上，所以它到处乱滑。你没事吧？你没事吧？你只需要一个沙袋。
Get a shot bag in there for you. I don't know, man. I just, all right. Are you guys, have we caught up? But really, I haven't caught up that much, but we've got it. I know, I haven't seen it. I'm just waiting and we'll,
在里面给你放个铅沙袋。我不知道，伙计。我只是，好吧。你们，我们叙过旧了吗？但真的，我还没怎么叙旧，不过我们已经。我知道，我还没看到。我正等着呢，而且我们会，
listen, our wheels in Atlanta haven't seen it for a couple weeks I know my heart hurts you. I see Much I'm coming home really soon. When are you coming? When do you come home? I'm gonna be home Tuesday. Did you sleep yesterday? We had a I did I talked to Sean last night. I was so Racked have you ever heard me that tired before Sean? No not my own my own life. And I just got, I was about to go to Ben Tronkold. I can't believe this is that. Maybe there's some kind of an emergency
听着，我们在亚特兰大的车已经几个星期没见到了，我知道，我心如刀割。我看到很多，我很快就要回家了。你什么时候回来？你什么时候回家？我星期二回家。你昨天睡觉了吗？我们有我睡了，我昨晚和肖恩聊了。我太累了，你以前听过我这么累吗，肖恩？没有，就我自己的生活而言。我刚刚，我差点就去文·特龙科尔德了。我真不敢相信这是。也许有什么紧急情况
with the Invisalign and I should pick this up. And maybe, maybe he choked on it. I got stuck in. Yeah, he thought it was like one of those sort of glass noodles or something that he did from the... A chin-shin special. Yeah. And so I picked up and then he was telling me about the dinner because obviously I
和隐适美有关，我应该去把这个拿回来。也许，也许他被它噎住了。卡在里面了。是的，他以为那是什么玻璃面条之类的东西，从……三鲜特制面。是的。所以我接了电话，然后他一直在跟我谈晚宴的事，因为显然我
couldn't be at the dinner with you guys. It was concerning stuff that we do together and I just was like, oh honey, because I'm like I literally just go, can I go? Can I go? Can I go in a row? I go, yeah, we know. Why did you even pick up? I realized I don't miss you that much. And let's get to our guest.
不能和你们一起去晚宴。那是我们一起做的重要事情，我当时就想，哦，亲爱的，因为我 literalmente（字面意思：我就）直接说，我可以走吗？我可以走吗？我可以连续走吗？我说，对，我们知道。你干嘛还要接电话？我意识到我没那么想你。让我们有请我们的嘉宾。
Guys, put all your dumb away and smarten up. Our guest today is a bright fella. And he has opened our eyes to quite a bit over the past few years. He's a graduate of Yale Law School. He's a member of the New York Bar. He has a PhD in political science from Oxford University, where he studied as a Rhodes scholar. And he served as a State Department official in Afghanistan and Pakistan.
伙计们，收起你们那些愚蠢的想法，打起精神来。我们今天的嘉宾是个聪明人。在过去的几年里，他让我们大开眼界。他是耶鲁法学院的毕业生，也是纽约律师协会的成员。他在牛津大学获得了政治学博士学位，曾是罗德学者。他曾在国务院担任阿富汗和巴基斯坦事务官员。
What have you two done? What's the gym? He has spent the last decade or two doing some of the most important investigative journalism in our country, both in print and through his production company. His recent and most high profile work has revealed many interesting and shocking facts about some of the most famous power figures in our country like Elon Musk, Donald Trump, Les Moonves and of course, Harvey Weinstein. Folks, please welcome Ronan Farrow.
你们两个都干了些什么？有什么好笑的？在过去的十年或二十年里，他一直在我们国家从事一些最重要的调查性新闻工作，包括印刷媒体和他的制作公司。他最近最受瞩目的工作揭露了许多关于我们国家一些最著名的权势人物的有趣且令人震惊的事实，比如埃隆·马斯克、唐纳德·特朗普、莱斯·穆恩夫斯，当然还有哈维·韦恩斯坦。各位，让我们欢迎罗南·法罗。
Whoa. Wait a minute. Ronan Farrow. That's tight enough. Ronan. That's amazing. Ronan came to the show this summer. Did he?
哇。等等。罗南·法罗。这太棒了。罗南。这太神奇了。罗南今年夏天来过节目。是吗？
I'd ask her. Yeah, I did. I saw a good night Oscar. It was amazing. I mean, thank you. You can really tingle the ivories. Well, that's a, that's a, you should, you should see him play piano. Ronan, did you go backstage and compliment Sean?
我问她。是的，我去了。我看过《晚安，奥斯卡》。太棒了。我的意思是，谢谢你。你弹钢琴真的很拿手。嗯，那是一个，那是一个，你应该，你应该看他弹钢琴。罗南，你去了后台称赞肖恩吗？
Yes. No, he did. Very nice. And I, I, I, I gushed over you as I will today. It's just a huge fan. Well, you're a sophisticated fan of all three of you. Thank you, Ronin, and I love you. That's a big reason to sing it.
是的。不，他去了。非常好。而且我，我，我，我像今天一样对你赞不绝口。简直是超级粉丝。好吧，你是我们三个人的资深粉丝。谢谢你，罗南，我爱你。这是一个很好的理由。
Even if it's not true, we appreciate it. No, it's very true. Also, by the way, the gravely baritone from you, I was like, you know, stifling, saying something, but it's so turn on when you turn on. It's a real thing to do. Yeah, no, no, no. No, I've done a good deal. I think he's talking about me!
即使这不是真的，我们也心领神会。不，这千真万确。另外，顺便说一句，你那低沉的男中音，我当时就想，你知道，强忍着不说点什么，但当你发出这种声音时，真的太性感了。这真是个绝活。对，不，不，不。不，我已经做得很好了。我想他在说我！
Ronan, you've got a voiceover quality voice. Have you ever done any? Do I love hearing that? Because I like very lightly dabble in anime and video game voice acting. Oh really? Is that true? Yeah.
罗南，你的声音很有配音演员的质感。你做过吗？我听到这个太高兴了，因为我非常喜欢涉足动漫和电子游戏配音。哦，真的吗？真的吗？是的。
Just because more that I'm a nerd than anything else, you know, like I did. I think I play a character called Mitsubishi Man who has like three lines and won Miyazaki movie. Really? It's a guy who will fix your catalytic converter with no questions asked. Where are you, where are you, our conditioner? No, you are, as I said, you're a sophisticated New Yorker that frequency arts. Can you confirm for me this thing where if you go see a play and you're, and you have
与其说是因为别的，不如说是因为我是个书呆子，你知道的，比如我做过。我想我在一部宫崎骏的电影里给一个叫三菱男的角色配过音，他只有三句台词。真的吗？这是一个会毫不犹豫帮你的催化转化器进行修理的家伙。你在哪儿，你在哪儿，我们的空调？不，正如我所说，你是一个很有品位的纽约客，而且很有艺术感。你能为我证实一件事吗：如果你去看一盘戏，而且你是，而且你
a, you have a recognizable name, you are obligated to go backstage. Jason's obsessed. Well, I just, I need to know if you don't go backstage. So funny. So much. You love talking about that. Regardless of whether you know anyone in the cast, if you're, if you're somewhat known, if you don't go backstage, they know about it and they think you hated the show.
有一个，你有一个广为人知的名字，你就有义务去后台吗？杰森对此着迷。好吧，我只是想知道如果你不去后台会怎么样。太搞笑了。太搞笑了。你太喜欢谈这个了。不管你认不认识剧组里的任何人，如果你稍微有点名气，如果你不去后台，他们就会知道，并且会觉得你讨厌这场演出。
And so you kind of have to go backstage say, hi, I'm famous. You're gonna have to love the show. There so you kind of have to go back and say, hi, I'm famous, your friend. You have to love the show. There's a, there's a letter. Let him answer. I love this runner through the different episodes of this show. It's one of the bits of commentary I love with you on your
所以你多少得去后台说，嗨，我很出名。你一定很喜欢这场演出。在那里，所以你多少得去后台说，嗨，我很出名，你的朋友。你一定得喜欢这场演出。这有一个，有一封信。让他回答。我喜欢在这档节目的不同剧集中看到这个梗。这是我最喜欢的关于你对其他名人的互动的评论之一。
interactions with other famous people. And the ways in which they're great or not great. But it sounds like mostly you sort of you do a little theater of it's not all great, but then all the points you make are about how great it is. Yeah. Well, you should also know that he's also trying to gauge where he, because he's been famous since he was really young, so he's looking back at his life and he's like, how many times have I been a dip? A lot of I've been rude. I think that's part of it. Well the truth is, I think about
以及他们表现得好与不好的方式。但听起来好像主要是你演了一出戏，觉得并不是样样都好，但随后你提出的所有观点都是关于它有多好。是的。好吧，你还应该知道，他也在试图权衡他自己的情况，因为他从小就很有名，所以他在回顾自己的生活时会想：我有多少次像个混蛋？我有很多次都很粗鲁。我想这也是其中一部分。好吧，事实是，我经常
this a lot, like because I also had this crucible of tabloid bullsh** around me as a kid. And then I did work that got me even more. And yeah, so I think about it a lot. And the particular kind of work I do where it's an occupational hazard to piss people off, who then either go to jail or get fired or something, and then they have nothing but time and money to come after me. Right.
考虑这个问题，因为我小时候周围也有这种小报乱七八糟的审判。然后我做的工作让这种审判更多了。是的，所以我经常思考这个问题。我从事的那种特殊工作，惹恼别人是一种职业风险，这些人要么锒铛入狱，要么被解雇什么的，然后他们有的是时间和金钱来找我的麻烦。没错。
There's a real genuine mix of good and bad and the kind of- Well, I want to get into that, but quickly end this silly question of mine. Like just like, I just find it like, hey, you're famous on famous. It's like why I'm backstage. But is that true? Is that an acceptable thing in New York culture just to go back simply because you're also famous? It does seem to always happen. And I think there's a bit of a sense of obligation, right? That you almost experience. So if
这里面确实有一种真实存在的、好的与坏的混合体，这种——好吧，我本想深入探讨，但先快点结束我这个愚蠢的问题吧。就好像，我只是觉得，嘿，你有名，我也有名。这就好比为什么我在后台。但这是真的吗？在纽约文化中，仅仅因为你也出名就去后台，是一件可以接受的事情吗？这似乎总是会发生。而且我觉得有一种责任感，对吧？你几乎能体会到这一点。所以如果
you know someone in the show or like peripherally or connected to them, then it feels like a little bit of no that'science. That's the rule. Yeah. Thank you for your indulgence. Now, let's get to what you were talking about because it was deeper in my question line up here, but let's get right to it about, you know, you're incredible investigative journalism has yielded some unhappy folks on the other side, I would imagine. So how do you sort of get yourself ready
你认识剧组里的某个人，或者有边缘上的联系，那就感觉有点……不，那是科学。那是规则。谢谢你的包容。现在，让我们谈谈你刚才说的话，因为它在我的问题清单里比较靠后，但让我们直奔主题吧，你知道的，你那令人难以置信的调查性新闻工作让对方的一些人不高兴了，我想象得到。那么，你是如何让自己做好准备
for the possible blowback? Like, I mean, all the way up to and including, do you have 24 hour a day's security? Was that something that you ever had to consider? I don't. I mean, I almost, I hesitate to say it, to create a job for people. But yeah, I've been followed around and staked out
应对可能到来的反扑的呢？我是说，一直到并且包括，你是否有24小时的全天候安保？这是你曾经不得不考虑的事情吗？我没有。我是说，我甚至有点犹豫要不要说出来，以免给别人制造就业机会。但是的，我曾被人跟踪、盯梢，
and had to like, not be in my apartment or Jesus. Actually, in one case, the weirdest, like physical surveillance coming after me, thing was not even the getting followed around, but when I did some reporting that ultimately was at the heart of the first of those Trump indictments at the about the Hush payments during the election. The catch and involved. In all of his relationship.
还不得不离开我的公寓，天哪。事实上，在其中一个案子里，最奇怪的、针对我的实际监视并不是被跟踪，而是当我做了一些报道，这些报道最终成为关于特朗普在选举期间封口费的第一次起诉的核心部分时。掩盖与压制。关于他所有的关系。
Yeah, exactly. The catching and killing of stories on his behalf by the national inquirer. Yeah, right. And the inquirer, which was led by some very vindictive people. And in some ways was a sort of blackmail or blackmail adjacent business model that they had come up with.
对，没错。国民问询报代表他掩盖和压制新闻。是的，没错。这家由一些非常记仇的人领导的问询报。在某种程度上，这是一种敲诈勒索或与敲诈勒索擦边的商业模式，是他们想出来的。
I don't know. Like, there were people seducing me. They like they published my like sex with someone. This is like, you can imagine the dress issues forever. You know, I'm just like, you know. But they've been very good about surveillance and I put in quotes research for years and years and years. That's sort of their their model right so they they had a bunch of Yeah, and I got all these these messages from celebrities who have been brutalized by them
我不知道。比如，有人色诱我。他们甚至发表了我和某人的性爱经历。你可以想象那些没完没了的麻烦事。你知道，我只是觉得，你知道的。但他们在监视方面一直非常在行，我把这加上了引号，多年来一直如此。这可以说是他们的模式，对吧？所以他们有一群——是的，我收到了所有这些被他们残害的名人的信息，
And endured similar things and like God. Thank you for for writing about this But but despite all of that I haven't gone to the place of Getting around the clock security. Yeah, I don't even know how I would make that work economically. And the truth is, I don't wanna overstate the case. Like I'm very conscious with the work I've done in different parts of the world.
他们也经历过类似的事情，并且说，天哪，谢谢你写了这些报道。但尽管如此，我并没有走到需要全天候安保的地步。是的，我甚至不知道从经济上讲我该如何让它维持下去。老实说，我不想夸大其词。我非常清楚我在世界各地不同地方做过的工作。
I actually did a film with two wonderful filmmakers, Heidi Ewing and Rachel Grady. That was just a frenemy, a prop out of them. I can take very little credit because they did all of everything on the creative end, but following journalists under threat through the pandemic. Yeah.
我实际上和两位出色的电影制作人海蒂·尤因（Heidi Ewing）和雷切尔·格雷迪（Rachel Grady）合作过一部电影。这只是个友情客串，我其实没出什么力，因为创意方面的一切都是她们做的，但影片讲述的是在疫情期间追踪面临威胁的记者。是的。
So seeing a lot of those stories of people whose lives are in jeopardy all the time, I'm very conscious of the fact that this is a much lower grade thing. I experience him in a country with good rule of law and like it's psychologically taxing, but the actual sort of getting followed around height of threats to physical safety,
所以看到许多那些生活时刻处于危险之中的人的故事，我很清楚地意识到，我所经历的远没有那么严重。我生活在一个法治健全的国家，虽然这在心理上令人筋疲力尽，但实际上面临的被跟踪和人身安全威胁的高峰，
I feel is something that ebbs and flows, and I've been okay without heavy security. Right, but you're talking about endangered, right? I mean, this was, yeah, about the sort of that, the encroachment on press freedoms. And do you feel like maybe this is kind of the start of that possible encroachment here by leaning on folks like you that are uncovering,
我觉得是会有起伏的，而且没有严密的安保我也过得挺好。对，但你刚才说的是处于危险之中，对吧？我是说，这是关于对新闻自由的侵蚀。你是否觉得这可能是这里可能发生的这种侵蚀的开始，通过施压像你这样正在揭露那些
you know, necessary truths that we all need to know about. But they're trying to keep that stuff down by intimidating journalists. Is that a creeping problem in this country? Well, I certainly agree with the idea that it is a creeping problem, broadly speaking, whether I'm representative of that or not. And I think it's something we need to talk about more because it's not just journalism that's at stake.
我们大家都需要知道的必要真相的人？但他们正试图通过恐吓记者来压制这些事情。这是这个国家一个日渐严重的问题吗？嗯，我当然同意这是一个日益严重的问题的观点，不管我是不是这种现象的代表。我认为这是我们需要更多讨论的事情，因为不仅仅是新闻业危在旦夕。
It's a sign of encroaching fascism, right? This is not a new thing in history. It's one of the tactics that gets deployed, this characterization of the press as an enemy of the people that we saw during the Trump administration. That is, tail is old as time. That's sort of the first thing to try to separate the public from the facts and reduce accountability so that people can pursue. Don't believe what you hear.
这是法西斯主义侵蚀的迹象，对吧？这在历史上并不是新鲜事。这是被采用的策略之一，也就是在特朗普政府期间我们看到的将媒体妖魔化为“人民的敌人”的这种定性。这真是古已有之。这基本上是试图将公众与事实隔离开来，减少问责制，以便人们可以追求——别相信你听到的。
Power, unjustly, yeah. Yeah. It feels like the first play in the playbook is to money the waters. And if you can do that, and then, and then, then you can, then people just don't know what to believe. Right. So they can't free for all. Right.
不义之财，对。是的。感觉剧本里的第一招就是把水搅浑。如果你能做到这一点，然后，然后，然后你就能，人们就不知道该相信什么了。对。这样他们就可以为所欲为了。对。
It's a free roll. So you can't, forget reading about the truth. You can't discern between the, because you can't trust any of it, right? And that's what they want. And if you can build that level of distrust, then you're winning. You don't never, it'll never win. It'll never win. And of course, the press is imperfect.
这是一个稳赚不赔的买卖。所以你不能，别去读什么真相了。你无法辨别，因为你什么都不能相信，对吧？这正是他们想要的。如果你能建立起那种程度的不信任，那么你就赢了。它永远不会赢。它永远不会赢。当然，新闻界并不完美。
And sometimes it's own worst enemy. I mean, I've done a lot of writing about the brokenness of media institutions and the suppression of important stories and stuff. And I've experienced some of that. I occupy an odd place in this discourse because I've been on all sides of it, because it's hard for people, I think, to absorb this as a truth,
有时它甚至是它自己最大的敌人。我的意思是，我写过很多关于媒体机构的破碎性以及对重要报道的压制之类的文章。我也经历过其中一些事情。在这个话语场中，我占据了一个奇怪的位置，因为我经历过它的各个方面，因为我认为人们很难接受这样一个事实：
that the skepticism about the existence of journalists that aren't motivated by partisanship is very extreme right now. So when I do a story about the adversely effects of Democrat and then a story that adversely effects the Republican, it's like that each of those constituencies affected doesn't see the other piece of what I'm doing. So I'll get moments where Tucker Carlson is doing
对于是否存在不受党派动机驱使的记者的怀疑，现在已经非常极端了。所以当我做了一篇对民主党产生不利影响的报道，接着又做了一篇对共和党产生不利影响的报道时，受影响的每一个群体似乎都看不到我正在做的另一部分。所以有时塔克·卡尔森会做
a really flattering monologue about how I'm heroic for exposing some Democrat. I never agreed to do that show to be clear, as a matter of principle. But like it was an odd, strange bedfellows thing that the right was very into some of this reporting when it suited them. But then I do reporting that was on flattering
一段非常奉承的独白，说我是因为揭露了某个民主党人而成为英雄。需要说明的是，我从未同意去那个节目，这是一个原则问题。但这就好像是一种奇怪的、同床异梦的情况，当对右翼有利时，他们非常喜欢其中的一些报道。但随后我做了一些对共和党不那么恭维的报道，
to a Republican and I'd get the opposite, I get all this like blowback and reputational smears and stuff. So yeah, it's a time I'm very disillusioned with in terms of the challenge. Do you see a fixed, I know it's such a general question, but do you see a fix to this issue about how people now absorb the news that they get? Obviously, it's again, a topic that's tails,
就会得到相反的结果，我会遭到所有这些反扑、名誉抹黑之类的东西。所以，是的，这是一个让我对这种挑战感到非常幻灭的时代。你认为有一个解决办法吗？我知道这是一个非常笼统的问题，但你认为对于人们现在如何吸收他们接收到的新闻这个问题，有什么解决办法吗？显然，这又是一个老生常谈的话题，
is everybody's fed what they want to read and what they want to absorb and digest. How do you break through to get the truth out to everybody all at once? Is there a person? Is there an outlet? Is there a thing? Is there a future where all of us will get
每个人都被喂食他们想读的和想吸收消化的东西。你如何突破重围，把真相同时传达给所有人？有没有这样一个人？有没有这样一个出口？有没有这样一种东西？有没有这样一个未来，我们所有人都能在同一时间获得
all the same facts at the same time? It's really hard. I don't think we're going to have to. Sorry, you didn't wrap it. Sean, you're starting to sound like Jason. I know. Jason always wants to.
所有相同的事实？这真的很难。我不认为我们会。抱歉，你没有做结语。肖恩，你听起来越来越像杰森了。我知道。杰森总是想。
He's always. I want answers. You've had such an offence. He's spreading. Is it there an absolute truth that we can then just refer to? Can we fix this before the end? I really like that aspect of this show. There is whether you guys want to cop to it or not.
他总是。我想要答案。你受到的冒犯太大了。他在蔓延。是否存在一个我们可以参考的绝对真理？我们能在结束前解决这个问题吗？我真的很喜欢这个节目的这一方面。不管你们承不承认，
There's an idealism in these conversations that you have. For sure. It's very nice. It's blissfully ignorant. Yeah, we're simple folks. But it's a pleasure. I didn't mean interrupt. Sorry, I just wanted to point that out.
你们进行这些对话时带着一种理想主义。确实如此。这非常好。这是一种幸福的无知。对，我们都是单纯的人。但这是一种乐趣。我不是故意打断的。抱歉，我只是想指出这一点。
I don't think there's an easy answer to this. I don't think we're going back to the Walter Cronkait monoculture. And I don't think we're going back to the same kind of trust institutions. There is a lot of things that feed into this. The declining trust in institutions is in all sectors.
我认为对此没有简单的答案。我不认为我们会回到沃尔特·克朗凯特（Walter Cronkite）的单一文化时代。我也不认为我们会回到对机构的同等信任状态。有很多因素导致了这一点。对机构信任度的下降发生在所有行业。
It's particularly acute with media. But it is a general trend line. Technology obviously changes this in an irreversible way, particularly the kind of the greedy algorithms that have come to understand that extremism and misinformation sells better, generates more clicks, and experts on radicalization talk about this a lot, that the way those algorithms work is like,
在媒体领域尤其严重。但这总的来说是一个普遍趋势。技术显然以不可逆转的方式改变了这一点，尤其是那种贪婪的算法，它们已经了解到极端主义和错误信息更好卖、能产生更多的点击量，而激进化专家经常谈到这一点，这些算法的工作方式就像是，
if you get someone, I did all this work, unmasking people in security camera footage during the January 6th, right? Yeah. You know, in the Siege of the Capital. There was a sort of crowdsource movement. Can you not? They were just tourists running.
如果你把某个人——我做了所有这些工作，在1月6日的监控录像中人肉出那些人，对吧？是的。你知道的，在国会山围攻事件中。当时有一种众包运动。你能不能别这样？他们只是去参观的游客。
What did it step into? Have you ever seen the end of it? It's a horror. Have you ever seen the end of it? It's a horror. Have you ever seen the end of it? Have you ever seen the end of it? Have you ever seen the end of it? Have you ever seen the end of it? Have you ever seen the end of it? Have you ever seen the end of it? Have you ever seen the end of it? What if that was the time when the story did not see any of the footage?
你踩到什么了？你见过最后的结果吗？那是一场灾难。你见过最后的结果吗？那是一场灾难。你见过最后的结果吗？你见过最后的结果吗？你见过最后的结果吗？你见过最后的结果吗？你见过最后的结果吗？你见过最后的结果吗？你见过最后的结果吗？如果那是故事中完全没有看到任何录像的时候呢？
There is a, they're walking through. They were touring. Anyway. Yeah, that's it. That's what my story said, actually, like these lovely tourists. Sure. The crowd was scrubbing through these videos framed by frame, like using facial recognition and trying all sorts of ways to find these people.
有一个，他们正在走过。他们在参观。不管怎样。是的，就是这样。实际上，我的报道就是这么说的，就像这些可爱的游客。当然。人群正在逐帧筛选这些视频，使用面部识别技术，并试图用各种方法找到这些人。
And I was able to identify a few collaborating with those people who were doing that crowdsource movement at a time when they were on the run and had not surrendered themselves to the FBI, but there were wanted posters and stuff. And I highlight that context partly because you wouldn't think they would be confessional at a moment like that, but they all were.
我能够通过与那些从事众包运动的人合作，确认其中几个人的身份，当时他们正在逃亡，还没有向联邦调查局自首，但通缉令什么的已经贴出来了。我强调这个背景部分是因为你不会认为他们在那种时刻会坦白，但他们都坦白了。
And the through line, obviously each case was different, was definitely this phenomenon we're talking about. It's the Pennsylvania mom who has eight kids and she gets on Facebook and it's showing her extremist stuff and they happen to grab someone like that who's already mad at mask mandates and then they just get fed more and more content
显而易见，每个案件都不同，但贯穿其中的共同点绝对是我们正在谈论的这种现象。比如那个有八个孩子的宾夕法尼亚妈妈，她上了Facebook，上面给她推送极端主义的内容，而他们恰好抓住了这样一个原本就对口罩令感到愤怒的人，然后不断地向她喂食越来越多的内容，
to escalating it. She's like, I have all of them, they got her. Yeah, and it's the, I don't mean to put soul blame on that, but it's a definite factor, and it goes to the point that you're making, that everyone is sort of in their own bubble,
使其不断升级。她就觉得，我全都……他们抓住她了。是的，而且，我不是要把全部责任归咎于此，但这绝对是一个因素，这也印证了你所提出的观点，即每个人都处在自己的泡沫中，
consuming things that they agree with, and it encourages them to dig in more deeply, rather than do the thing we should all be doing, obviously, which is to be open-minded to the facts wherever they may lead. Yeah. We'll be right back. Thank you to Helix for supporting Smartless.
消费着他们赞同的内容，这促使他们更加固执己见，而不是去做我们本都应该做的事情，很显然，那就是无论事实指向何方都要保持开放的心态。我们马上回来。感谢Helix对《聪明笨蛋》的大力支持。
Now, listen, if you like me when you go to sleep, you like your sleep to be similar to getting in the way of some sort of a trunk dart. And these people at Helix, they know how to fire it, and it'll hit you right between the eyes, okay? Boom. That's what my incredible Helix midnight mattress really does for me.
听着，如果你像我一样，睡觉时希望有那种像是被某种麻醉镖击中的感觉。而Helix的这些家伙，他们知道怎么发射，它会正好击中你的眉心，好吧？砰。这就是我那不可思议的Helix Midnight床垫真正为我带来的效果。
So the Helix lineup offers 20 unique mattresses, including the award-winning Luxe collection, the newly released Helix Elite Collection, a mattress designed for big and tall sleepers, and even a mattress made just for kids. All right, so the Helix Elite Collection, it includes six different mattress models, each tailored for specific sleep positions
Helix的产品线提供20种独特的床垫，包括备受赞誉的Luxe系列、新发布的Helix Elite系列、专为高大身材睡眠者设计的床垫，甚至是专为儿童制造的床垫。好的，Helix Elite系列包含六种不同的床垫型号，每一种都针对特定的睡眠姿势和硬度偏好量身定制。
and firmness preferences. When you're nervous about buying a mattress online, you don't need to beat. The Helix Sleep Quiz takes into account for individual sleep preferences to match you and your partner with the perfect mattress for you. You really want to feel like you're knocked out, you want that Helix midnight. You want some sort of a light, restful sleep. I'm sure they got one for that. You want something that's perfect for naps, I'll bet they got some kind of a nap mattress.
当你对在线购买床垫感到紧张时，大可不必。Helix睡眠测试会考虑到个人的睡眠偏好，为你和你的伴侣匹配最完美的床垫。如果你真的想体验被打晕的感觉，你需要那张Helix Midnight。如果你想要某种轻松、安稳的睡眠，我确信他们也有对应的产品。如果你想要一张最适合小睡的床垫，我敢打赌他们也有某种午睡床垫。
These people have it covered. Your personalized mattress is shipped straight to your door. It's free of charge. Don't wanna take my word for it's fine. Helix Sleep has over 12,000 five star reviews. So you don't even need to believe me. Listen, Helix is offering 20% off all mattress orders
这些人应有尽有。你个性化的床垫会直接送到你家门口。完全免费。如果你不相信我的话也没关系。Helix Sleep拥有超过12,000条五星好评。所以你甚至不需要相信我。听着，Helix目前为我们的听众提供所有床垫订单8折优惠
and two free pillows for our listeners. Go to helixleap.com slash smart list. This is their best offer yet and it will not last long. With Helix better sleep starts right now. By supporting Helix, you're allowing them to support the show. Go purchase your Helix and thank us later for your best night's sleep. Helixleap.com slash Smarmus. [♪ Music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing in background, music playing feel special and unique, just like the relationship we share. That's why I'm giving everyone I care about story worth. Story worth is an online service that helps you and your loved ones
以及两个免费枕头。访问helixsleep.com/smartless。这是他们迄今为止最好的优惠，而且不会持续太久。有了Helix，更优质的睡眠现在就开始。通过支持Helix，你也在让他们支持本节目。快去购买你的Helix床垫，并在享受了你此生最棒的睡眠后向我们道谢吧。helixsleep.com/smartless。[♪ 背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中，背景音乐播放中感觉特别而独特，就像我们分享的关系一样。这就是为什么我要把我关心的人都送上一份StoryWorth。StoryWorth是一个在线服务，可以帮助你和你的挚爱
preserve precious memories and stories for years to come. It's a thoughtful and meaningful gift that connects you to those who matter most. Every week, Zell works every week. Story worth emails your relative or friend with a thought provoking question of your choice from their vast pool of possible options. Each unique prompt asks questions you've never thought to ask. Like, what's the bravest thing you've ever done in your life? Or if you could see into the future, what would you want to find out?
在未来几年里保存珍贵的记忆和故事。这是一份体贴而有意义的礼物，能将你与那些对你最重要的人紧密联系在一起。每周，Zell每周都在运作。StoryWorth会给你的亲戚或朋友发送一封电子邮件，里面有你从他们海量可选问题库中精心挑选的、引人深思的问题。每一个独特的问题都会问出你从未想过要问的事。比如，你这辈子做过最勇敢的事情是什么？或者如果你能预知未来，你想查明什么？
See? So, after one year story worth, we'll compile all of your loved ones' stories, including photos, into a beautiful keepsake book that you'll be able to share and revisit for generations to come. After one year story worth, we'll compile all of your loved ones' stories, including photos, into a beautiful keepsake book that you'll be able to share and revisit for generations to come. Sounds great, right? So, reading the weekly stories helps connect you with loved ones, no matter how near or far apart you are. So I don't know.
看到了吗？因此，在经过一年的StoryWorth之后，他们会将你挚爱的所有故事（包括照片）汇编成一本精美的纪念册，供你们在未来世世代代分享和重温。在经过一年的StoryWorth之后，他们会将你挚爱的所有故事（包括照片）汇编成一本精美的纪念册，供你们在未来世世代代分享和重温。听起来很棒，对吧？因此，阅读每周的故事有助于拉近你与挚爱的距离，无论你们相距多么遥远。所以我不知道。
You can hear it in my voice what you're hearing is excitement about the holiday season is coming forward. And then I get to use this story worth. I'm hungover. With story worth, I'm giving those I love most, a thoughtful personal gift from the heart and preserving their memories and stories for years to come. Go to storyworth.com slash smartless and save $10 on your first purchase. That's storyworth.com slash smartless to save $10 on your first purchase.
你可以从我的声音中听出来，你听到的是对即将到来的节日季的兴奋之情。然后我就可以使用这个StoryWorth了。我宿醉了。通过StoryWorth，我把我最爱的人送上了一份来自心底的贴心个人礼物，并为他们未来几年保存了记忆和故事。访问storyworth.com/smartless，首次购买可节省10美元。这就是storyworth.com/smartless，首次购买可节省10美元。
Happy holidays, y'all. Smartless is sponsored by BetterHelp. Now, here in my family, we are, we love giving gifts, but sometimes, you know, we'll sort of like, you know, give each other helpful suggestions or wanna be surprised, certain members of the family like to be surprised, other members don't, it all, everyone's got their own different thing,
祝大家节日快乐。SmartLess由BetterHelp赞助。现在，在我的家庭里，我们，我们非常喜欢送礼物，但有时，你知道，我们会互相提供一些有用的建议，或者想要给对方一个惊喜，家庭中的某些成员喜欢惊喜，而另一些则不然，总之，每个人都有自己不同的习惯，
but here's the thing, you get to decide how you give to yourself, right? And the holidays are a great time to do that. So whether it's by starting therapy, going easier on yourself during tough moments or treating yourself to a day of complete rest, whatever it is, remember to give yourself some love this holiday season, okay? Like, for instance, therapy is something that I've given to myself over the years. My goodness, I could always take more and more and more every time I gift myself that I feel like I've unwrapped a package of happiness and clarity, right? Yes, you get
但关键是，你可以决定如何犒劳自己，对吧？而假期正是这样做的绝佳时机。因此，无论是通过开始心理咨询、在艰难时刻对自己好一点，还是用一整天的彻底休息来款待自己，无论是什么，请记得在这个节日季给自己一些关爱，好吗？比如，心理咨询就是我多年来一直送给自己的一份礼物。天哪，我总是可以接受更多更多更多，每次我把这份礼物送给自己时，我都觉得仿佛拆开了一包快乐和清晰的礼物，对吧？是的，你懂的
it. All right. If you're thinking about starting therapy, give better help. Try. It's entirely online. It's designed to be convenient, flexible, and suited to your schedule. Just fill out a brief questionnaire to get matched with a licensed therapist and switch therapists any time for no additional charge. In the season of giving, give yourself what you need with BetterHelp. Visit BetterHelp.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's BetterHelpHELP.com slash smartless today to get 10% off your first month. That's betterhelp help.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. I'd like to get into our guest a little bit here about where one gets the amount of intelligence
。好吧。如果你正在考虑开始心理咨询，不妨试试BetterHelp。它完全在线上进行，旨在提供便利、灵活且适合你日程安排的服务。只需填写一份简单的问卷，就能与持证心理咨询师匹配，并且可以随时免费更换咨询师。在这个奉献的季节，用BetterHelp给予自己所需的一切。今天就访问BetterHelp.com/smartless，首月即可享受9折优惠。这就是BetterHelpHELP.com/smartless，今天首月即可享受9折优惠。即betterhelp help.com/smartless。现在让我们回到节目中。我想稍微了解一下我们的嘉宾，关于一个人如何能拥有塞满你脑袋的那种惊人智慧。那么，当年，你小时候是不是吃了很多小麦胚芽？是不是有什么胡萝卜或者——那是饮食。我只是觉得——我不知道。如果你喂你的孩子足够的小麦胚芽，他们就能获得普利策奖。这就是我听说过的。好吧，实锤了。
you've managed to pack inside your head there. Now,, was there a lot of, did you eat a lot of wheat germ as a kid? Was there like carrots or- That was diet. I just thought- I don't know. If you feed your kid enough wheat germ, they will get a Pulitzer Grat. That's what I've heard. Okay, confirmed.
就写在盒子里。对，对。等等，成为罗德学者需要什么条件？因为我想——不，那是小麦胚芽加上个性，我当时在想。呃，当听到这类问题的某种变体时，我其实很想说一些极其疯狂的话。比如，你知道的，我就学乔·罗根（Joe Rogan）的那套，就当乔是对的。
It's in the box. Yeah, yeah. Wait, what do you need to become a Rhodes scholar? Because I want to- No, that's wheat germ German character at some thinking. Um, I was tempted by the way when I get some variation on this question to say something truly insane. Like, you know, I just eat the Joe Rogan thing like Joe is right.
我每次都吃六罐沙丁鱼。他是这么说的吗？冷水浴。然后你进行冷水浴。对，就是这样。你真的很推崇沙丁鱼吗？对，对，最近之前有一条小新闻，他显然认为自己
I eat six tens of sardines every time. Is that what he said? Cold plunge. And then you cold, you cold your plunge. Yeah, that's it. Cold plunge. You really swear by Sardines? Yeah, yeah, there was a little news item before recently where he apparently thought he
我每次吃六十条沙丁鱼。他是这么说的吗？冷水浸泡。然后你冷水，你冷水浸泡。对，就是这样。冷水浸泡。你真的很信奉沙丁鱼吗？对，对，之前最近有一个小新闻，他显然认为他
was getting poisoned because he was like getting getting too much mercury from the Sardines. Sure. I think about Sardines and I get bloated. No, they're, oh no, they're very good and they are very healthy and modern. There's a lot of sodium guys. Well, they're not predator fish. There's, there's, there's, there's, the full of're full of salt in my face. That's always safer in terms of the contempt. Now I I want to do what you're doing. I appreciate you. No, I can't
因为摄入沙丁鱼过量，导致自己汞中毒。当然。我觉得沙丁鱼就会让我觉得腹胀。不，它们，噢不，它们非常好，非常健康，也很现代。里面有很多钠，伙计们。好吧，它们不是掠食性鱼类。这里有……里面全都是盐，直接糊在我脸上。从有害物质的含量来看，这样总是更安全。现在我想做你正在做的事。我很感激你。不，我不能
do this in any of you. Doesn't know. Um, quiet. Well, um, so you skipped a few grades. Quite you skipped a few grades in school. You entered college at a very young age. I want to know how know how that sort of educational experience, yeah, a few grades. What was it? It was seven. It was seven grades. I did a two key house or thing.
在你们任何一个人身上做这件事。不知道。嗯，安静。好吧，嗯，所以你跳了几级。挺安静的，你在学校跳了几级。你很小的时候就上了大学。我想知道那种教育经历是怎样的，对，跳了几级。那是几级？是七级。我上的是那种双人班之类的。
No, you did not. No, no, no, no. Why am I so socially maladjusted, guys? No, no, no, there's only 12 grades before college. You skipped seven of those? I skipped seven of them. Yeah, I went to college at 11. Are you serious?
不，你才没有。不，不，不，不。为什么我的社交这么不适应，伙计们？不，不，不，上大学前总共只有12个年级。你跳了其中七个？我跳了七个。对，我11岁就上大学了。你是认真的吗？
Hold that shit. Wait a second. Wait, Ronan, you went to Yale at 11? No, I went to Bard for undergrad at 11. I got into Yale at 15, 16. I actually took a little time then to do, did some unicef work. Cause it was like a youth spokesperson
等等。等一下。等等，罗南，你11岁就上了耶鲁？不，我11岁时去巴德学院读本科。我15、16岁时考入了耶鲁。其实我当时花了一点时间去做了点联合国儿童基金会的工作。因为我当时是一个青年代言人
and a couple of African people. I mean, I'm really proud of my children, but I live at a less now. Hey, hey, Roman, ask these guys what the last book they read was. Yeah. Oh, are we avid readers here or no? Well, this is a smart group, joke, so.
和几个非洲人。我的意思是，我真的很为我的孩子们骄傲，但我现在住在一个更少……。嘿，嘿，罗南，问问这几个人他们读的上一本书是什么。啊，我们这里有狂热的读者吗，还是没有？好吧，这是一个聪明的组合，开个玩笑。
I enjoyed Tom Sawyer a lot. Does that count? Let's go and go back. Up a very thin. What about you? What the last book I read? The last book. Pamplets don't count.
我很喜欢《汤姆·索亚历险记》。那算吗？让我们回去。找一个很薄的。你呢？我读的最后一本书是什么？最后一本书。小册子不算。
The Giving Tree. I don't know. So this guy's writing books. Ronan, when was the, when was your last book that you wrote? Hello, we got a catch and kill 2019. I think I have the next one that's going to be a book. So I'm, I'm doing have the next one that's gonna be a book, though. I'm doing this sort of...
《爱心树》。我不知道。所以这家伙在写书。罗南，你写的上一本书是什么时候？你好，我们有2019年的《捕杀》。我想我的下一本会是一本书。所以，我有下一本将要出版的书。我正在做这种……
Are we making news? I know. We like to make news on this. No, I can't ever get into specifics on like investigative topics that haven't hatched yet, because of course. I always, further to the point of like people can be skeptical or not,
我们在制造新闻吗？我知道。我们喜欢在这个节目里制造新闻。不，我从来不能透露那些还没出炉的调查报道的具体细节，因为当然。我总是，更进一步说，关于人们是否持怀疑态度，
but I am genuinely led by what's the biggest but also most interesting and hopefully humanistic story, like how can I fair it out the intricacies of the characters involved and be compassionate in the portrayal of even the bad people and so forth. Sure. And it's not about politics and part of that being led by the facts and making sure that those are the kinds of stories that I do and the way that I do them is I have to be willing to like throw them in the trash if they don't pan out.
但我确实是由以下原则真诚驱动的：什么是最大但也是最有趣、且充满人文关怀的故事，比如我如何厘清其中人物的复杂关系，并对即使是坏人等角色也抱有同情心。当然。这与政治无关，而遵循事实、确保我做的就是那种故事、并以那种方式去做的一部分，就是我必须准备好在它们行不通时把它们扔进垃圾桶。
I've done six months of work on a really giant political story that I didn't think was wrong, factually, but I felt like it wasn't the misconduct being alleged, it wasn't serious enough, and the way the facts came together wasn't bullet proof. We're fine with hearsay, if you wanna just let us know, just the rumors. Yeah, yeah, I'll just give you the guts. enough and the way the facts came together wasn't bullet proof. We're fine with your safe. You want to just let us know just the rumors.
我曾花六个月时间做了一篇非常重大的政治报道，在事实上我认为它没有错，但我觉得它所指控的不当行为不够严重，而且事实拼凑在一起也不是无懈可击的。如果你只是想让我们知道，哪怕只是传闻，我们也完全接受道听途说。对，对，我只会把核心内容给你。不够严重，而且事实拼凑在一起也不是无懈可击的。如果你只是想让我们知道，哪怕只是传闻，我们也完全接受道听途说。
Yeah, yeah, I'll just give you the guts. I'll give you the guts. So I can't talk about specifics, but yeah, I'm doing this like trans media approach in a lot of cases where I'll do a print story for the New Yorker and then either during or after some combination do it as a podcast or NHBO series, my documentary business is at HBO, which has been interesting
对，对，我只会把核心内容给你。我把核心内容给你。所以我不能谈论具体细节，但是，是的，在很多情况下我采用了这种跨媒介的方法，我会为《纽约客》写一篇印刷版报道，然后要么在期间要么之后，以某种组合方式把它做成播客或HBO系列节目，我的纪录片业务就在HBO，这一直很有趣
because I think, you know, I grew up with like a love of film and I've got my start as a TV news anchor and I do love being able to tell the stories in different ways. But what is it, one of my questions I think Sean was saying, he was going to ask you this too, how do you pick? And I'm sure you've answered this a million times, I apologize, but what guides your picking of stuff to investigate? It's a matrix of different factors. I think you want to assess, will it potentially do some good in the world?
因为我觉得，你知道的，我从小就热爱电影，我是作为一名电视新闻主播出道的，我也确实喜欢能够以不同的方式讲述故事。但这是什么，我的问题之一，肖恩之前好像说过，他也要问你这个，你是怎么挑选的？我确信你已经回答过这个问题上百万次了，我很抱歉，但是是什么指导你选择要去调查的内容的？这是多种不同因素的矩阵。我觉得你要评估，它有可能对世界产生一些好的影响吗？
Not in an activist way, where it's not an op-ed when I'm doing this particular kind of relatively clinical investigative work, but you do want to find some social relevance in it. Yeah, you want to pick the stories where something potentially could change, not necessarily because you're proposing a specific change, but because those are the exciting, meaningful stories a lot of the time that cause people to sit up and take notice. And then you are looking at not just the strengths of the facts and constantly assessing as the
不是以激进主义的方式，当我做这种相对理性的调查工作时，它不是一篇社论，但你确实希望在其中找到一些社会相关性。是的，你想要挑选那些某些事情可能会发生改变的故事，不一定是因为你提出了具体的改变，而是因为在很多时候，那些是激动人心的、有意义的故事，能让人眼前一亮。然后你不仅要看事实的力度，还要随着
facts come in, okay, is this like a slam dunk story on the journalistic side, but also, especially as you move between those different formats, is it a narrative arc that people can relate to and understand emotionally? Are there people involved that are rich, complicated characters that people will potentially connect to? Talk to us about the thing that really drew you to public service in government and how that changed or didn't change, meaning is it the same thing that drew you into journalism? Was it a sense of altruism that then transferred into something different or did you find the same draw on both? Well, it's like probably for most of us
事实的不断涌现而持续评估：好吧，这在新闻层面上是不是一个稳操胜券的故事？同时，特别是当你在这些不同的形式之间转换时，它是否是一个人们能够产生共鸣并在情感上理解的叙事弧光？其中涉及的人物是否是那种人们可能会产生联系的丰富、复杂的人物？跟我们聊聊是什么真正吸引你投身政府公共服务，以及这后来是如何改变或没有改变的，也就是说，这跟吸引你进入新闻界的是同一回事吗？是一种利他主义最终转化成了别的东西，还是你在两者身上找到了相同的吸引力？好吧，这可能对我们大多数人来说
to some extent or other, there's a mix of altruism and belief in public service and caring about other people, and narcissism and ego and wanting to be successful and that led to most of these decisions you're asking about. I was very fortunate to grow up with my mom, who is a big fan of yours Jason, by the way. I was a big fan of hers. I'm so lucky to have worked with her.
在某种程度上，既有对利他主义和公共服务信念的结合，也有对关心他人的关切，同时还有自恋、自我以及对成功的渴望，这些促成了你所问的大多数决定。我很幸运，我的妈妈抚养我长大，顺便说一句，她也是你的超级粉丝，杰森。我是她的超级粉丝。能和她合作我太幸运了。
I really like you. Yeah, I like her a lot. I hope you guys get to work together again. I'm trying to encourage her to work with her. This was actually a film for the Weinstein company called The X with Zach Braff and Amanda Pete and Charles Groden and Mia. Oh yeah. I played an asshole in a wheelchair. Wait, wasn't Amy in that? What's that?
我真的很喜欢你。对，我很喜欢她。我希望你们能有机会再次合作。我正试图鼓励她和她合作。这其实是韦恩斯坦公司的一部电影，叫《中间人》，由扎克·布拉夫、阿曼达·皮特、查尔斯·格罗丁和米亚主演。哦，对。我在里面演了一个坐轮椅的混蛋。等等，艾米不是也演了那个吗？什么？
Yeah, I think Amy was in the M.I. In armises. What was it called? It was called The X. It was actually, if I recall, from the deepest recesses of my mind, it was a script at the time titled Fast Track, and it was like a workplace comedy.
对，我记得艾米在M.I.中。在阿米塞斯。那叫什么名字？它叫《中间人》。如果我从脑海最深处的记忆中搜寻的话，其实它当时是一个剧本，题为《快车道》，就像是一部职场喜剧。
And then Harvey Weinstein acquired it and did a very Harvey Weinstein thing, which did reshoots and recut it and changed the premise that it was then called the X, and it was a relationship comedy. I'm not sure where the title change came from, but I do remember very clearly the whole reshoot scenario where the title changed, but I do remember very clearly the whole reshoot
然后哈维·韦恩斯坦买下了它，并做了一件非常哈维·韦恩斯坦风格的事，那就是进行补拍、重新剪辑，并改变了前提，后来它被命名为《中间人》，成了一部情感喜剧。我不确定片名是怎么改的，但我确实清楚地记得整个补拍方案，当时片名改了，但我确实清楚地记得整个补拍
scenario where I played an asshole in a wheelchair going after Zach Braff's girlfriend, Amanda Pete, and his Zach Braff's character's theory was that I was faking it in the wheelchair. That he's making grounds on my lady because my lady feels bad for him. And he's not even injured. He's faking it in the wheelchair. And the truth is that I really was somebody that couldn't walk. And then they tested the movie and my character
方案，我演一个坐在轮椅上的混蛋，去追求扎克·布拉夫的女友阿曼达·皮特，而扎克·布拉夫角色的理论是，我坐在轮椅上是装出来的。他正在抢我的女人，因为我的女人对我很同情。而他甚至都没有受伤。他是坐在轮椅上装的。而事实是，我确实是个无法走路的人。然后他们对电影进行了试映，我的角色
was testing a little bit too likable. Because you know, he was an asshole in the wheelchair. He's fun to, fun to hate. I thought you were gonna say, yeah, you know, because you know, I'm too likable because you know he was an asshole in wheelchairs funded funded fund a hate. I thought you were gonna say yeah you know because you know I'm so like well. And so they figured well now that's making Zach Raff's character seem very unlikeable because he's the lead and he's trying to you know expose me anyway. So their big idea was to well let's make it so that he really is faking it to adjust the and so that was going to be the reshoot and was the reshoot.
试映时显得有点太讨人喜欢了。因为你知道的，他是一个坐在轮椅上的混蛋。他很有趣，让人恨不起来。我以为你会说，对，你知道的，因为你知道我太讨人喜欢了，因为你知道他是一个坐在轮椅上的混蛋，很有趣，让人恨不起来。我以为你会说，对，你知道的，因为你知道我太好了。所以他们觉得，好吧，现在这让扎克·布拉夫的角色显得非常不讨人喜欢，因为他是主角，而且他无论如何都想揭穿我。所以他们的重大主意就是，好吧，让我们把它改成他真的是装出来的，来调整……所以这将是补拍内容，而且也确实补拍了。
There was a big scene we had a reshoot where I stand up. And I was like, well, wait a second. I don't know if I'd play the character if I knew he was faking it. And I had a phone call with Harvey Weinstein, where I said, oh, I said, what's the, what are the screen actors guild rules? Where you, can you really just make me reshoot a scene
有一个很大的场景，我们补拍了一场我站起来的戏。当时我就想，嗯，等一下。如果我知道这个角色是装的，我不知道我还会不会演。我跟哈维·韦恩斯坦通了电话，我说，哦，我说，美国演员工会的规则是什么？你们真的可以让我补拍一场
that changes the character completely and now I'm a guy who's faking it and I he's like, yep, you're doing it. I was like, okay, Doc, we shot like 30 pages of the pages. Yeah, she was a Jesse Parrots director. The great Jesse Parrots. Wow. Yeah. Anyway,ots directed it. The great Jesse Parrots. Wow. Yeah. Anyway, Mia was awesome.
完全改变了角色的戏吗？现在我成了一个装病的人，而他却说：“没错，你得拍。”我说：“好吧，医生。”我们拍了大约30页的剧本。对，导演是杰西·帕罗茨。伟大的杰西·帕罗茨。哇。对。不管怎样，帕罗茨导演的。伟大的杰西·帕罗茨。哇。对。不管怎样，米亚太棒了。
Well, we're on the digression. Yeah, I have been trying to encourage my mom to be more game to work. I think there was a period of time where she just, she had so many bad industry experiences. It really came after her. There was Woody Allen bullshit. And she's sort of, she's such an incredible actress.
好吧，我们扯远了。对，我一直在试图鼓励我妈妈更愿意去工作。我觉得有一段时间她只是，她在业内有太多糟糕的经历。这真的给她带来了很大的创伤。有伍迪·艾伦的那些废话。而且她有点，她是一位如此不可思议的演员。
And because of those experiences, because she started as a kid basically, and she was on a beaten place as a teenager, she doesn't fully own her talent in the way that I hope she can. Every time she does something, people are so bold over. She keeps people so much. So much. Yeah.
正是因为那些经历，因为她基本上从小就开始演戏，十几岁时就在一个饱受挫折的环境中，她并没有完全认可自己的才华，不像我所希望的那样。每次她做点什么，人们都会被深深地震撼。她总是给人们那么多。那么多。对。
So yeah, so I'm kind of just trying to encourage her to own that. Yeah, well, it's kind of it's kind of absurd that you're talking about Mia Farrow. Yeah. Mom, I was like, I wish you wanted to get one of the great actresses. Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. You should really get out there and realize how good she is. Because, you know, to someone from me who didn't grow up close to that sort of thing, I think I think, of course.
所以，是的，我基本上只是在试图鼓励她去认可这一点。对，好吧，你谈论的是米亚·法罗，这有点，有点荒谬。对。妈妈，我当时就想，我希望你想成为伟大的女演员之一。对，对，对，对，对，对，对。你应该真正走出去，意识到自己有多优秀。因为，你知道的，对于像我这样没有在那种环境中长大的人来说，我想，我想，当然。
Pretty cool. And you did grow up so close to that, which must have, it's interesting that you, I mean, that you just went kind of 180 degrees away from that in a lot of ways, right? I mean, that you just went into academia. Well, I didn't, I didn't. I did in the practical sense of the choices that I was making, but actually the philosophical underpinning very much comes from her.
非常酷。而你确实是在那种非常亲密的环境中长大的，这一定……很有趣的是，你，我是说，你在很多方面都直接来了个180度的大转弯，对吧？我是说，你直接走进了学术界。嗯，我没有，我没有。从我所做选择的现实意义上来说，我确实这么做了，但实际上其哲学基础很大程度上来自于她。
She is like altruistic, I think at times to a fault. It's genuine too. It's not performative. She really is like obsessed with helping people and has probably made questionable decisions at time because of it. I mean, she adopted all of these kids with special needs, which was this beautiful, wonderful thing,
她简直是利他主义的，有时我觉得甚至有些过头了。而且这也是真诚的。不是那种表演性质的。她真的是那种痴迷于帮助别人的人，并且往往会因此做出一些值得商榷的决定。我的意思是，她收养了所有这些有特殊需求的儿童，这是一个美丽、美妙的事情，
but also a source of much, much chaos in my childhood. I was just gonna say. Yeah, so it's complicated. Did she ever pull over and try to pick up a hitchhiker? I think she felt like they needed a ride and it was just a real bad decision. She was very much that kind of person. And I think it's taken a lot of being brutalized
但这也是我童年中许多许多混乱的根源。我正想这么说。对，所以情况很复杂。她有没有曾经把车停在路边去试图接上一个搭便车的人？我想她觉得他们需要搭车，而这只是一个非常糟糕的决定。她就是那种人。我想这需要经历被世界
by the world to disobey her of that. Mother, do not slow down the car. What's happening? But from a perspective, you can talk about it as much or we can cut it or whatever. But just from a perspective of me growing up with a single mom and a large family, not nearly as large as yours.
百般摧残，才能让她放弃这种想法。母亲，请不要减速。发生什么事了？但从一个角度来看，你可以随心所欲地谈论它，或者我们可以剪掉它之类的。但仅从我由一个单亲妈妈和一个大家庭抚养长大的角度来看，虽然不像你的家庭那么庞大，
What was that like, because I always say, we kind of all had to figure out, even though we had an amazing mom, like your mom, my mom was incredible too, and ran a food bank for the poor and the homeless, and some of the food we got was from the food bank because we were in that situation too. But so I put my mom in a pedestal's too.
那是怎样的感受，因为我总是说，我们其实都必须自己去摸索，尽管我们有一个了不起的妈妈，就像你的妈妈一样，我的妈妈也很不可思议，她为穷人和无家可归者经营一家食物银行，我们得到的一些食物也是从食物银行拿来的，因为我们也处在那样的境地中。所以我也把我的妈妈放在了神坛上。
At the same time, we had a kind of parent ourselves And did you growing up in such a large family feel that sense because there's so many kids? You know, you'd have to ask my different siblings about their experience of that My perception was always is one of the amazing things about her. She was Incredibly attentive like she knit every single one of us, a Christmas stalking with our name on it and like a relevant graphic. As holidays were real rituals.
与此同时，我们有点不得不自己抚养自己。你在这么一个大家庭里长大，有没有那种感觉，因为有太多的孩子？你知道的，你得去问我的不同兄弟姐妹对那段经历的感受。我的看法一直是，她最了不起的地方之一就是：她
So she even in the midst of a lot of chaos and painful stuff and, you know, me getting dragged in and out of courtrooms and rammed through crowds of paparazzi and helicopters overhead, you know overhead to get to school. There was a lot of, and also loss. So I had a lot of immediate family members die over the course of my childhood.
极其细心。比如她给我们每个人都亲手织了一只圣诞袜，上面绣着我们的名字和相关的图案。假期真的就像是仪式一样。
So there was a lot there that didn't work, but one of the things that did work is what you're asking about. Like she's an incredibly attentive mom. Yeah, same. Almost in a superhuman way. And all of that redounded to me, really caring in my world view about compassion
所以，即使身处大量的混乱和痛苦之中，你知道的，我被拖进拖出法庭，在一群狗仔队和头顶直升机的包围下被推搡着去上学。当时有很多，还有失去。在我的童年过程中，我有许多直系亲属去世。
and altruism. And, and, yeah. Look, I think there are pros and cons to this. The moral framework I was given was like, we're not really here, she would deny this by the way, but my interpretation of it anyways, that we're, I was taught not to care about personal happiness,
所以那里有很多事情是没有奏效的，但确实奏效的事情之一就是你刚才问的那样。就像她是一个极其细心的妈妈。对，我也是。几乎是以一种超人的方式。所有这一切最终都促成了我在世界观上真正关心同情心
that the first goal was your here with privilege and responsibilities, and you must work to improve the lives of others. And that is the source of true happiness. But that's the very long-winded answer to your question that I wanted to do things that helped others. How big is your therapist's yacht? Because...
和利他主义。还有，还有，是的。看，我认为这有利有弊。我被灌输的道德框架是，我们来这里不是为了别的——她顺便会否认这一点——但无论如何我的理解是，我们被教导不要去在乎个人幸福，
Yeah, that's a lot of stuff. Here's the craziest thing. Well, I only did therapy for the first time, other than like, cord-appointed expert stuff in my childhood, which is probably why I then didn't leap to therapy after. You would make a therapist so happy, though, because your ability to articulate your feelings and you are so beautifully vulnerable and human and I bet you could have no credible conversations with a therapist.
首要目标是你带着特权和责任来到这里，你必须努力去改善别人的生活。这就是真正幸福的源泉。但这对于你关于我想做一些帮助别人的事情的问题，是一个非常冗长的回答。你的心理医生的游艇有多大？因为……
I mean, I've loved mine. Well, I have found it late in life. Like during the pandemic, I was actually, it did take hitting a bit of psychological rock bottom. I had been driving so hard with the philosophy that we've been talking about. Like, I've just got a give and give and give. And to the point I made earlier about
对，那真是相当多的事情。最疯狂的事情是：好吧，我直到第一次才真正做心理治疗，除了我童年时那些法庭指定的专家咨询之外，这可能就是为什么我当时没有马上跳进心理治疗的原因。不过你会让心理医生非常高兴，因为你清晰表达自己感受的能力，而且你又是如此美好地脆弱和真实，我敢打赌你可以和心理医生进行不可思议的对话。
it being a cocktail of selfish and giving instincts. Like, I also, I had been so scrutinized from such an early age and with so much expectation, I wanted to do things that were 180 from my family. I wanted to be taken seriously. My early professional experiences where I'd be talking about an infrastructure project
我的意思是，我一直很爱我的心理医生。好吧，我是晚年才找到这个方法的。比如在大流行期间，我实际上确实经历了一次心理上的触底反弹。我一直带着我们刚才讨论的那种哲学拼命向前冲。就像，我必须不断地付出、付出、再付出。结合我之前提到的
in Pakistan and they'd like, want to ask me about my family and stuff, just made me very, very committed to being so, so serious and such an overachiever that I could get out of that. And it took becoming so, so kind of souped up and like prominent in my own right for my work. I had to be involved in these like major kind of culture shifting moments to get out of that.
这是自私与奉献本能的鸡尾酒。就像，我也，我从很小的时候起就受到严密的审视，背负着那么多的期望，我想做一些与我的家庭180度相反的事情。我想被认真对待。我早期的职业经历是，当我谈论巴基斯坦的一个基础设施项目时，他们却想问我关于我家庭之类的事，这让我非常非常坚定地想要变得如此严肃、如此力争上游，以至于我能摆脱那种阴影。为了摆脱它，我不得不让自己变得如此这般动力十足、在自己的领域里出类拔萃。我不得不参与到那些重大的、改变文化的时刻中去。
And then finally I could do it. I could go on a book tour and never get asked about my family. I did it. Yeah. It had downsides though. I think I alienated myself from people by over credentialing.
然后我终于做到了。我可以去进行图书巡回签售，而再也不会被问到关于我家庭的事。我做到了。是的。不过这也有消极的一面。我觉得我通过过度包装自己而疏远了身边的人。
Have you ever talked to Anderson Cooper about it? We talked a little bit about, you know, he would, he, he's gay. You must know him. He's gay. Yeah, that's what I guess. Well, we do all, I mean, I, you know, I see him and Sean at the gay, you know, I knew it. I fucking, I fucking hang on. Let me write this down.
你有没有跟安德森·库珀谈过这事？我们稍微聊过，你知道的，他会，他，他是同性恋。你一定认识他。他是同性恋。对，我想是的。好吧，我们确实都，我是说，你知道的，我和肖恩在同性恋，你知道的，我早就知道了。我他妈的，我他妈的，等一下。让我把这个记下来。
Let me write this down. No, but I was going to say that I remember he had a very sort of similar answer when he would say that that was the thing that was always the sort of the flag, the red flag when he was on a date. If how soon somebody asked about his mom and of course, hilariously, he talked about how Andy go and he asked him in like 10 seconds. But so they became good friends. But but yeah, I mean, that's a difficult thing, right? I also have, well, that's good. You also have a very, very famous friend of ours, very close that you would know. And this person comes from an extreme...
让我把它记下来。不，但我想说的是，我记得他有一个非常类似的回答，他说每当他在约会时，那总是某种信号，某种危险信号——当别人有多快问起关于他妈妈的事时。当然，最搞笑的是，他说安迪去约会时，对方在大概10秒钟内就问了他这个问题。于是他们成了好朋友。但是，是的，我的意思是，这是一件很难的事情，对吧？我还拥有，好吧，这很好。你还有一个非常非常著名的我们的朋友，你们都很熟，你也认识。这个人来自一个极其……
I don't know, do you know Milton Burrell? Ha ha ha ha. This person comes from an extremely famous family that everybody knows. And this person to your point, Ronan, is what's shunned. All questions didn't want to talk about her family. Her identity is not that.
我不知道，你认识米尔顿·伯勒吗？哈哈哈哈哈。这个人来自一个大家都知道的极其著名的家庭。罗南，正如你所说，这个人遭到了回避。所有的问题都不想谈论她的家庭。她的身份不是那个。
I do not, you know, I am this person over here. I've created this world for myself. And in doing so through many, many, many, many years of evolution and growth, she was like, she learned the balance of embracing both, right? And bringing that in and not being not ashamed at all. It's just, it's your own personal identity and figuring out the path that's in the middle somewhere.
我才不，你知道的，我是这边这个人。我为自己创造了这个世界。而在通过多年、多年、多年、多年的演变和成长做到这一点的过程中，她就像是，她学会了拥抱两者的平衡，对吧？把这些融入进来，一点也不感到羞耻。这只是你个人的身份，并找出介于两者之间的某种平衡。
I've had that journey myself. I remember vividly, so there's fame, and then there's this particular subgenre of fame that's particularly awful and enduring in a troublesome way of fame connected to generationally defining sex scandal. And there's just a kind of prerence and shock element that 30 years later does not go away. And I remember vividly running into Chelsea Clinton at some event. And this was before I had done a lot professionally.
我自己也有过这段旅程。我清晰地记得，盛名是一回事，然后还有这种特殊的次类型声名，它特别糟糕且持久，并以一种令人烦恼的方式与定义时代的性丑闻联系在一起。那种猎奇和震惊的元素在30年後依然不会消散。我清晰地记得在某次活动上碰到了切尔西·克林顿。这发生在我职业生涯取得很大成就之前。
I think it was right as I was getting out of it. I just recently met her. What a great woman. She's so, so, I think it was right out. So I was getting out of it. I just recently met her. What a great woman. She's so, so, I'm really interested in it. Well, she's probably one of the few people who has that very, very specific, awful shadow over her, from childhood. And worse than me, right?
我想那正是我刚要摆脱它的时候。我最近才认识她。真是个伟大的女性。她太，太，我想那正是刚要。所以我正要摆脱它。我最近才认识她。真是个伟大的女性。她太，太，我对她很感兴趣。好吧，她可能是为数不多的几个在童年时期就背负着那种非常、非常具体且可怕阴影的人之一。比我还惨，对吧？
Because she was in the White House dealing with it all the, but similar in some ways. And I remember this is, prior to me having done any work in the world, and people really only knew me through that family stuff. And someone came up at this event and was like introducing me or saying hello to me in a way that foregrounded the family stuff, like, oh, you know, here's this is a nebo baby, or whatever.
因为她在白宫里处理这一切，但在某些方面又很相似。我记得这是在我从事任何世界性工作之前，人们真的只通过那些家庭的事情才知道我。在这次活动中有人走过来，以一种将家庭背景置于前台的方式向我介绍或打招呼，比如，哦，你知道，这是个星二代，诸如此类。
And she was so forceful, I don't know if she would even recall this, but she was clearly, she had the same chip on her shoulder that I had was my reading of it which may or may not be fair to her, but she was like, he's his own person, like he's done his own things. I'm gonna like Chelsea, are you talking about you? And I do think like different people respond to that in different ways, but for me I've learned the peril of that. First of all, because if you refuse to talk about it, people are just much more curious. Second of all, I think the wanting to dissociate yourself from it
她是如此强势，我不知道她是否还记得这一点，但很明显，她有着和我一样的反叛心理，这是我的解读，对她来说可能公平也可能不公平，但她的意思是：他是他自己，他做了他自己的事。我要像切尔西一样，你在说你自己吗？我也确实认为，不同的人对这一点会有不同的反应，但对我来说，我已经懂得了其中的危险。首先，如果你拒绝谈论它，人们反而会更加好奇。其次，我认为想要与它划清界限
is very fair and understandable, but ultimately, kind of finding peace in yourself does require reconciling all of those parts of you and all of those parts of your past. Yes. And drawing strength from it. Yes, and you've got to get a lot of that managed before you start
是非常公平和可以理解的，但归根结底，在内心获得平静确实需要与你所有的那些部分以及你过去的那些部分达成和解。是的。并从中汲取力量。是的，在你开始组建
what becomes your new immediate family. Yeah. And now, a word from a sponsor. Thank you to Zippercrooter for their support. Now, you know, holidays are here. There, I've got a list of people to get stuff for. Some of them are sort of, they're tough to buy for. You know, they're very specific.
成为你新的直系家庭之前，你必须先把很多事情处理好。是的。现在，有请赞助商广告。感谢 ZipRecruiter 的支持。现在，你知道的，假期到了。好了，我有一长串要送礼的人。其中有些人有点难挑礼物。你知道的，他们很有品味。
Others are sort of just like happy to open up something. You, I give, this one person, I just give an empty box every year, but it's beautifully wrapped. And they're thrilled. No, that's not true, but you get what I'm saying. If you're a business owner, guys, you need to grow your team. But if you're if you're a business owner, guys, stay with me here, and you need to grow your team, your perfect gift is simple. You want a smart hiring solution, you'll look no further than Zip Recruiter. And right now, we're gifting it to you for free at zippercruder.com slash smartness.
其他人则只是很高兴能打开任何礼物。你，我给，这个人，我每年只给一个空盒子，但它包装得很精美。他们会欣喜若狂。不，那不是真的，但你明白我的意思。如果你是一个企业主，伙计们，你需要壮大你的团队。但是如果你，如果你是一个企业主，伙计们，听我说，你需要壮大你的团队，你完美的礼物很简单。你想要一个智能招聘解决方案，找 ZipRecruiter 就对了。现在，我们在 zippercruiter.com/smartness 上免费把它送给你。
How is zippercruder a gift to those who are hiring? Zippercruder uses smart matching technology to identify the most qualified people for a wide range of roles. Zippercruder lets top candidates know when they're a great match for your job to encourage them to apply. And the bow on top, if you see a candidate who's a great match for your job to encourage them to apply. And the bow on top, if you see a candidate
ZipRecruiter 如何成为招聘人员的礼物？ZipRecruiter 使用智能匹配技术，为各种职位甄选出最合格的人选。ZipRecruiter 会在候选人与你的职位非常契合时通知他们，从而鼓励他们申请。锦上添花的是，如果你看到一个候选人
who's a great match for your job, Zippercruder makes it easy to send them a personal invite, so they're more likely to apply. Get it? Okay. So get your hiring wrapped up quickly with Zippercruder, four out of five employees who post on Zippercruder get a quality candidate within the first date. Just go to this exclusive web address right now to try Zippercr for free. Zipper Cruder.com slash smartless. Again, that's zipper Cruder.com slash S-M-A-R-T-L-E sponsored by ADT.
与你的职位非常契合，ZipRecruiter 可以让你轻松向他们发送个人邀请，这样他们就更有可能申请。懂了吗？好了。因此，通过 ZipRecruiter 快速搞定你的招聘工作，在 ZipRecruiter 上发布招聘信息的雇主中，五分之四的人在第一天就能找到优质候选人。现在就访问这个专属网址，免费试用 ZipRecruiter。ZipRecruiter.com/smartless。再次强调，网址是 zipperCruder.com/s-m-a-r-t-l-e 由 ADT 赞助。
ADT Self Setup features everything from motion sensors to Google Nest Cam's with no long-term contracts. Easily install the ADT Self Setup Security System at your convenience. No heavy-duty tools are needed and if you need help, ADT can provide virtual assistance along the way. So these guys are friendly too. Look at that. ADT self-set up grows, moves, and adapts as your needs change.
ADT 自助安装系统功能齐全，从运动传感器到 Google Nest 摄像头应有尽有，且无需长期合同。您可以随时轻松安装 ADT 自助安装安全系统。无需重型工具，如果您需要帮助，ADT 可以全程提供虚拟协助。所以这些人也很友好。你看。ADT 自助安装系统能够随着您的需求变化而成长、移动和适应。
You can add more products at any time and your system easily moves wherever life takes you. It also features Nest Cam's that can tell the difference between a person, an animal, a vehicle, or with the Nest doorbell, even a package. Plus, when every second counts, you can trust ADT's 24-7 professional monitoring. You can view video of an alarm event and verify or cancel an alarm with just a tap. When the most trusted name and home security adds the intelligence of Google, you've got a home with no worries.
您可以随时添加更多产品，无论生活将您带向何方，您的系统都可以轻松随行。它还配备了 Nest 摄像头，能够区分人、动物、车辆，甚至通过 Nest 门铃识别包裹。此外，当分秒必争时，您可以信赖 ADT 的 7x24 小时专业监控。您只需轻轻一点，就可以查看报警事件的视频并验证或取消警报。当家庭安全领域的名牌结合了谷歌的智能技术时，您就拥有了一个无忧无虑的家。
Go to ADT.com today or call 1-800-ADT-ASAP, Google Nest Cam, Nest Doorbell, and Nest Aware are trademarks of Google LLC. SmartLess is supported by GoodRX. Now, we are in a season where you've got to kind of watch it or you're going to get a cold. You're going to get sniffles, you're going to feel ache, you're going to, you know, it's just it's out there. So you got to keep your head on swivel. If you're feeling under the weather, this cold and flu season, good RX is here to help. With big savings on prescription, cold and flu meds and tons of information to help you and your family stay healthy. This winter, with GoodRx, you can instantly find discounts,
今天就访问 ADT.com 或致电 1-800-ADT-ASAP。Google Nest Cam、Nest Doorbell 和 Nest Aware 是 Google LLC 的商标。SmartLess 获得 GoodRX 的支持。现在，正值换季时节，你得当心点，否则就会感冒。你会流鼻涕，会感到酸痛，你会，你知道的，这病就在外面晃荡。所以你得时刻保持警惕。如果你在这个感冒和流感季节感到身体不适，GoodRx 来帮忙了。通过处方感冒和流感药物的大幅折扣，以及海量信息，帮助你和你的家人在这个冬天保持健康。通过 GoodRx，你可以立即找到折扣，
compare prices, and save up to 80% at the pharmacy. All you need to do is search for your medication on the GoodRx website or app, and show your discount at the pharmacy. It's that easy. GoodRx is accepted at all the major pharmacies in your neighborhood, including CVS, Walgreens, Rhydaed, Vons, Walmart, Sam's Club, and many more.
在药店比价并节省高达 80% 的费用。你所需要做的就是在 GoodRx 网站或应用上搜索你的药物，并在药店出示你的折扣。就是这么简单。GoodRx 被你附近的各大药店所接受，包括 CVS、Walgreens、Rite Aid、Vons、Walmart、Sam's Club 等等。
And remember, goodRx is not insurance, but it works, whether you have insurance or not. Even if you have insurance, goodRx may beat your co-pay price. For big savings on cold and flu meds, plus discounts on your everyday prescriptions, go to goodrx.com slash smartless. Support the show and get amazing discounts by visiting our URL at goodrx.com slash smartless. And now back to the show. We all spend every single day of our lives with our mom, our dad, and our sibling until
请记住，GoodRx 不是保险，但无论你是否有保险，它都管用。即使你有保险，GoodRx 的价格也可能比你的共付额更划算。想要在感冒和流感药物上省大钱，并获得日常处方的折扣，请访问 goodrx.com/smartless。访问我们的网址 goodrx.com/smartless，支持节目并获得惊人的折扣。现在回到节目中。我们所有人的生命中，每天都和妈妈、爸爸以及兄弟姐妹在一起，直到
you're, you know, 18, 20, whatever it is. You move out and then you see them less. And then eventually you meet the person that becomes your everyday person, your spouse. And then you meet your kids, you know, when they're born. And you see the people you used to spend every day with, maybe once or twice, three, four times a year, at holidays and stuff, you know your friend. So how are you now transitioning into that place
你，你知道的，18岁、20岁，不管多大。你搬出去，然后见他们的次数就变少了。再然后，最终你遇到了那个成为你日常生活伴侣的人，你的配偶。接着你有了孩子，你知道的，当他们出生的时候。你会看到那些你以前每天都陪伴的人，也许一年一两次，三四次，在节日之类的日子里，你知道你的朋友。所以你现在如何过渡到那个位置
of family, the new meaning of family for you, for all of us is we become adult children. Yeah. Do you idealize the notion of family? What talked to us about your personal life, to the extent you're comfortable, about you said you want to have kids and all that stuff? Where is all that stuff set with you right now? Well, this goes back to the joke about therapy. I did actually, there was this moment in the pandemic where the work slowed down because the world was slowing down, but the attacks were still coming.
家庭的位置，对你、对我们所有人来说，家庭的新含义随着我们成为成年子女而改变。是的。你是否将家庭的概念理想化？跟我们谈谈你的个人生活，在你感到舒适的范围内，关于你说你想生孩子之类的事情？所有这些事情现在在你心里是怎么定位的？好吧，这回到了关于心理治疗的笑话。我确实经历过，在大流行期间有这样一个时刻，工作放缓了，因为世界放缓了，但攻击还在继续。
And it was like every day or at all hours getting these crazy shakedown attempts, like, going back to the inquirer example, like crazy letters from the inquirer having been pertained, like, idealog, right wing, crazy lawyers who might have actually brought a casing. We're going to see your pants off for defamation if you don't pass. Some crazy, it's like a joke. I'm at like $50 million overnight. And all of these like reputational smears and people I'd pissed off trafficking dossiers and once in a while they'd make their way into the mainstream press. And it's interesting, I've stumbled into all of this serious, pure-reviewed, psych literature
而且就像每天或在任何时候都会收到这些疯狂的敲诈勒索尝试，比如，回到问询报的例子，收到来自问询报的疯狂信件，涉及那些意识形态偏右、疯狂的律师，他们可能真的会提起诉讼。如果你不通过的话，我们要让你倾家荡产去打诽谤官司。有些疯狂的信件，简直是个笑话。我一夜之间就面临5000万美元的索赔。以及所有这些名誉摸黑，有些我曾惹恼过的人在倒卖档案，偶尔它们还会流传到主流媒体中。有趣的是，我无意中接触到所有这些严肃的、经过同行评审的心理学文献
about how attacks that threaten your core sense of identity and place in society are actually at times more ready instigators of PTSD symptoms than even threats of physical harm, that those are the ones that damage people the most. It was helpful for me to understand that because for a long time, I kind of kicked myself and beat myself up over it. I've been in war zones, I've been in dangerous situations, I've been followed around, but the shit I care about
关于那些威胁你核心身份认同和社会地位的攻击，有时其实比身体伤害的威胁更能引发创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）症状，这些攻击对人的伤害最大。理解这一点对我很有帮助，因为很长一段时间里，我一直在为这事自责和捶胸顿足。我去过战区，我去过危险的地方，我被人跟踪过，但我真正在乎的狗屁倒灶的事
is like, what is page six saying? Right, right. But it was really hard for me. And I finally did prompt me to start working on myself. And I did some, this goes to your question of, like, how do I build my adult identity and my path towards hopefully being a good partner and maybe eventually a good parent?
却是第6页都在说些什么？对，对。但这对我来说真的很艰难。它最终确实促使我开始审视自己。这也引出了你的问题：我如何建立我的成年身份，以及如何迈向有望成为一个好伴侣、最终可能成为一个好父母的道路？
I started putting in the work. And I did a couple of years of cognitive behavioral therapy and then found a great, more traditional analyst. I think those tools can work for some people, not work for some people. There's good practitioners, bad practitioners, but I did. I found someone great in the end and that was genuinely helpful for me. And I think part of allowing myself to work on that was not stepping away from but tempering the philosophy of like any minute I don't spend helping someone else,
我开始为此付出努力。我做了几年的认知行为疗法，然后找到了一位非常棒的、更传统的心理分析师。我认为这些工具对某些人管用，对某些人不管用。有好医生，也有庸医，但我确实找到了。我最终找到了一个很棒的人，这对我真的很有帮助。而且我认为，允许自己去从事这项工作的一部分，不是退缩，而是缓和这样一种哲学：哪怕有一分钟我没有用来帮助别人，
I am morally failing. Yeah. That letting myself work for myself occasionally. And it was extra hard for me to do that as someone who had always been in the press and people having these expectations. Yes, but the example that you lived with called your mother is, you know, we always, as we get to adulthood, we go, we rebel in different ways. And some of those are like, I see what my mom did in my, I'm speaking for myself.
我在道德上就是失败的。是的。就是偶尔允许自己为自己工作。作为一个一直处于媒体聚光灯下、人们有着种种期望的人，我要做到这一点格外困难。是的，但是你和你的母亲共同生活过的那个例子，你知道的，我们总是，当我们步入成年时，我们会以不同的方式叛逆。其中一些就像，我看到了我妈妈做了什么——我是在为我自己说话。
I see what she did. I see what she did to an extreme. And again, going back to the balance thing, which is the hardest for any human to do, is to balance, you know, the good from the bad and where do I lie in between. And as much as you celebrate your mom and I celebrate my mom, there are extremes, you know, and it's okay to recognize that and go,
我看到了她做了什么。我看到了她走向极端。再次回到平衡这件事上，这是任何人类做起来都最难的事，即平衡好与坏（的对立），以及我介于两者之间的什么位置。正如你赞美你的妈妈、我也赞美我的妈妈一样，事物总有极端，你知道的，承认这一点并说，
oh, where's me in all of this? Yeah, and you find your version of their advice and their guide. Yeah, yeah, yeah. Right, exactly that. And like, we aspire to do it better than our parents did it. Yeah. And we're gonna fuck it up inevitably in new and exciting ways.
哦，这一切当中哪个才是我？是的，你会找到他们建议和指引的你的版本。对，对，对。没错，正是如此。就像，我们渴望比我们的父母做得更好。是的。而且我们不可避免地会以新的、令人兴奋的方式把事情搞砸。
And, you know, we have to just be kind both to the parents. Like, I think part of this path is you're not idealizing your parents, but you are greeting their complications with kindness and understanding. And then part of it is also being kind to ourselves, right, as we make those things. Well, you have to let yourself off the hook
而且，你知道，我们必须对父母保持宽容——我认为这条道路的一部分是，你不会将父母理想化，而是以善良和理解来面对他们的复杂性。其中一部分也是对我们自己保持宽容，对吧，在我们做出那些事情的时候。好吧，你必须放过自己，
and you also can't let past them. You can't use, I think that one of the traps that I know that I have fallen into in the past and that I used to do more was to use those past experiences and to make my self feel shitty about it or to beat myself up about it. And believe me, if making, if beating yourself up about it worked, I'd be cured.
你也不能放过过去。你不能利用——我知道这是我过去常常陷入的陷阱之一，我也做得更多的——利用那些过去的经历来让自己感觉糟糕，或者用它来责备自己。相信我，如果责备自己管用的话，我早就被治愈了。
It doesn't work. Do you know what I mean? It just doesn't. I know exactly what you mean. I mean, I really have to work on this in an ongoing way because I have the most punishing interior voice. Just like anything I do that is not perfect, I am so cruel to myself. And I'm also, I'm like a hyper sensitized person to other people,
你懂我的意思吗？根本不管用。我完全明白你的意思。我的意思是，我真的必须持续地在这方面下功夫，因为我内心有一个极其严厉的声音。只要我做的任何事情不够完美，我对自己的态度就极其残忍。而且我也，我是一个对他人高度敏感的人，
and there's different bodies of literature that categorize that in different ways, but I'm like anxiously attached. I'm a super sensitive person. So, there's actually, there's these studies where people who exhibit those traits, they show them like videos of a face slowly morphing from one expression to another. And they actually, they detect the change earlier than other people,
有不同的文献以不同的方式对这一点进行分类，但我属于焦虑型依恋。我是一个超级敏感的人。所以，实际上，有这样一些研究：给那些表现出这些特征的人观看一些面部表情缓慢从一种转变为另一种的视频。他们确实比其他人更早地察觉到变化，
but they also have an inclination to draw conclusions from that prematurely. I do, I am, I completely relate to that. I completely relate to that. I completely identify with that. And I call it thin slicing. And I have, and I, I've long felt like I have an ability to thin slice and sometimes it to my own detriment. By the way, I also have a very punishing inner voice.
但他们也有过早从中得出结论的倾向。我，我完全感同身受。我完全能理解这一点。我完全对此有同感。我称之为“微切片”。而且我一直觉得自己有能力进行微切片，有时这反倒对我不利。顺便说一句，我内心也有一个非常严厉的声音。
And you're lucky because mine sounds like this. Mine is fucking right here. Mine's like you. Where am I so turned on? I do. You're cruel internal voice. I tell you so you. I suspect most performers.
而你是幸运的，因为我的声音听起来像这样。我的声音就在这里。我的声音就像你。为什么我这么兴奋？我确实。你那残忍的内心声音。我告诉你，所以你……我怀疑大多数表演者。
And I'm not a performer per se, but I do like make a living on TV. There's a performative aspect or a communicative aspect. I think a lot of those people are probably hyper sensitized in that way. And there's a nexus of the cruel interior voice and the public scrutiny and the hypersensitivity to the public scrutiny. Like, I care so much what other people think.
我虽然不是什么表演者本身，但我确实靠上电视谋生。这里面有表演的成分，也有沟通的成分。我想许多这样的人可能都是以那种方式高度敏感的。而且残忍的内心声音、公众的审视以及对公众审视的高度敏感之间存在着某种联系。比如，我在乎极了别人是怎么想的。
I care so much about the random Twitter, we cruel tweet, and there's so much cruelty. I think there gets a bad rap though. You know, I think that it's such a healthy thing to be, I think, aware of, as opposed to concerned with. It's just semantics. Well, how you're coming across, I mean, it's certainly what the three of us do for a living with acting, that's our job, we're professional liars in the way
我真的很在意那些随机的推特，那些残忍的推文，里面有太多的残酷。不过我觉得它名声不太好。你知道，我觉得意识到这一点是非常健康的，而不是去过分担忧。这只是语义问题。好吧，你们的表现方式，我是说，这绝对是我们三个人靠演戏谋生的方式，那是我们的工作，我们在表现自己的方式上是专业的骗子，对吧？
in which we come across, right? We're trying to trick people. And so in that comes an inherent ability or need were professional liars in the way in which we come across, right? We're trying to trick people. And so in that comes an inherent ability or need to know how you're coming across and to be concerned with whether that's an accurate perception. Well, first of all, the notion that people, when people say, and I've had it from people I grew up with, who have nothing to do with entertainment, and they're like, you know, they're all Canadians. So they all sound like this.
我们在试图捉弄人。所以这其中就包含了一种与生俱来的能力或需求，即我们知道自己是如何表现的，并关心这是否是一种准确的感知。首先，当人们说——我身边的很多朋友都这么说过，他们和娱乐圈毫无关系，而且他们全都是加拿大人。所以他们听起来都像这样。
Well, you guys care what you look like. Or you think you're, and I'm like, yeah, everybody does motherfucker. And nice try. And if you have them there, you can. And if everybody get it too, they want to be any story selling, selling fashion. And they want to be an in makeup for sale. And they want to be anything. So, A, go fuck yourself.
“好吧，你们这些家伙很在意自己的外表。或者你们觉得自己是……”而我会说：“废话，是个妈惹法克儿都在意。少来这套。如果你有条件，你也会。每个人都想这样，他们想卖任何故事、卖时尚。他们想化着妆出售自己。他们想兜售一切。所以，A，滚你妈的。”
And B, yeah, that's how I, you you know why because that's how I make my living And I get and we now live in a world where I get to hear everybody's opinion in real time for everywhere on the planet Yeah, and it makes it keeps you nicer if you're concerned or are aware aware of what people think about you I think you know to the extent you're able to handle it, then take it on because it keeps you kind, and it keeps you aware of other people. What is it that you do with that? Well, but this is Jason to end her up for a moment. What you just expressed, what you have taken away
B，是的，这就是我……你知道为什么吗？因为这就是我谋生的方式。而且现在我们生活在一个世界里，我可以实时听到地球上每个角落里每个人的意见。是的，这能让你变得更友善，如果你关心或者意识到人们对你的看法的话。我认为，只要你有能力承受，那就去接受它，因为它能让你保持善良，让你对他人保持觉察。你对此会怎么做？好吧，不过打断杰森一下。你刚才表达的，你从关于你自己的滔滔不绝的公众舆论风暴中体会到的，
from being in a firestorm of public opinion about yourself, it is not necessarily the norm, and I've seen all kinds of people who wind up very distorted by it, and it can lead to kind of more ego, but I'm fascinated by the fact that actually to what I can observe everyone in this group has taken from that experience
这并不一定是常态，我见过各种各样的人最终被它严重扭曲，这可能会导致某种程度的自我膨胀，但我着迷的事实是，事实上，据我观察，这个群体中的每个人都从那次经历中
all of these good, beautiful, caring things. Like how do you, how do you do that? I mean, I hope that I'm achieving that myself, but I'm interested in how they're stuff. Why do you, you seem self-aware. I mean, I think it's about being, first of all, it's about who you surround yourself with. Well, and also considering the sources,
汲取了所有这些美好、善良、关怀的东西。就像，你是怎么做到这一点的？我是说，我希望我自己也能达成这一点，但我对他们是如何做到这一点的很感兴趣。为什么你……你看起来很有自我觉察。我是说，我觉得这关乎……首先，这关乎你身边都是些什么人。还有，考虑信息来源，
like consider this sort, like anytime somebody, right, a horrible thing about me, there's been tons of stuff in my whole life. Yeah. It's like you go, at some point, you know, when you're much younger, I was like, oh my God, I'd cry and crawl in a corner. And I'm like, oh, that person is miserable, not me.
就像考虑来源一样，比如任何时候有人写了关于我的可怕事情，我一生中有过无数次这样的经历。是的。这就好像你会觉得，在某个时刻，当你年轻得多的时候，我会想，“哦，天哪，”我会哭泣，然后缩在角落里。而现在我会想，“哦，那个人很痛苦，不是我。”
When you were talking about your scary voice inside, the chastises you, what is the thing that wakes that monster up the most? What do you do? What do you do that most disappoints you? What's your dumbest shit? You're such a smart, insightful guy. I can't imagine you doing something that would really warrant a real real talking to.
当你在谈论你内心那个斥责你的可怕声音时，是什么最能唤醒那个怪物？你做了什么？你做了什么最让你自己失望的事？你干过最蠢的事是什么？你是个这么聪明、有洞察力的人。我无法想象你会做出什么真正需要被好好说教一番的事。
It's a good point. Yeah, it is almost always not rational. And I've been shielded both by my, I think, generally good, strong moral code and instincts, and also surrounding myself with other people who have those qualities. I've had points in my career very prominently where I've been with very, like, Craven, corporate, power-hungry people who, when the rubber meets the road and there's a tough story unfolding, they're awful, they're cowardly, and it's so disillusioning and disappointing. But I have over time been able to refine
这倒是个好点子。是的，它几乎从来都不是理性的。我一直受到我的——我认为是总体上良好、坚强的道德准则和直觉的庇护，同时也因为我身边都是具备这些品质的人。在我的职业生涯中，有些时候，非常引人注目的是，我和一些非常卑鄙、功利、权力熏心的人在一起，当关键时刻来临、有艰难的故事要展开时，他们糟糕透顶，懦弱无能，这太让人幻灭和失望了。但我随着时间推移已经能够重新定义
the chosen family professionally, not just personally, to include more people who are big-minded, big-hearted, have good values and have good systems for enforcing those values. So the New Yorker is this magical esoteric place where all of these intellectuals with tons of virtue, not that they get it perfectly right all the time, of course, it's human beings, but I have been so impressed, even in cases where there's a disagreement about a story and I'm the reporter saying, like, I've worked on this for months, I want to get it out. Here are all the arguments by. The counterarguments are always rooted in like good journalistic ethics.
职业上的“精选家庭”，不仅在个人层面上，还包括吸纳更多胸怀开阔、心地善良、价值观端正并且有良好机制来践行这些价值观的人。所以《纽约客》是一个神奇而神秘的地方，这里所有的知识分子都充满美德，并不是说他们每时每刻都能做到完美，当然，他们也是人，但我印象非常深刻，甚至在对某篇报道有分歧、而我是那个说“我已经为此工作了几个月，我想把它发表出来”的记者时。所有的论点……反驳的论点总是植根于良好的新闻伦理。
So I've been protected by that from the real mistake. There haven't been inaccuracies in the story even when the stories when they're under attack. It's withstood all of that. I have gradually come to trust myself more and be less punishing because I've seen over time that I do make good decisions. And I think I am increasingly trusting of the idea that I can pull off both. I can scrutinize my decisions and learn each time to be better without being punished. But you don't have one reoccurring blind spot.
所以我因此得到了保护，免于犯下真正的错误。报道中没有出现不准确之处，即使这些报道正受到攻击。它经受住了这一切考验。我渐渐开始更加信任自己，减少对自己的惩罚，因为我随着时间看到自己确实做出了正确的决定。而且我认为我越来越相信这样一个理念：我可以兼顾两者。我可以审视自己的决定，每次都吸取教训变得更好，而无需自我惩罚。难道你没有一个反复出现的盲点吗？
Like you're like, it's not always an angry driver and you're mad at yourself for honking it ever. Jason, Jason, what are the, sorry, just quickly, I'm gonna ask you, what are the things that you beat yourself up about it? And let me guess the first five. Yeah, I'm curious about this. First five, the first five you should.
就像你不会总是对一个愤怒的司机按喇叭，然后为此生自己的气一样。杰森，杰森，有什么……抱歉，简单问一下，你有哪些会自我责备的事情？让我来猜前五个。是的，我对这个很好奇。前五个，你最应该的。
Yeah, I guess that, let me rephrase how that like this time. I said, Jason, here is my list. Yeah, I guess that let me rephrase Jason Here is my list of my question like you talked to me about Sizing with with all you know you're just amazing your your brain is gorgeous and beautiful Your gorgeous and beautiful Everything your gorgeous and beautiful. Yeah, as is your skin, your hair, everything. I can lip-synamin' everything.
好吧，我想……让我重新表述一下……就像这次。我说：“杰森，这是我的清单。”是的，我想……让我重新表述，杰森，这是我的问题清单……就像你跟我谈论……赞同……带着你所知道的一切……你太棒了，你的大脑华丽而美丽。你华丽而美丽，你的一切都华丽而美丽。是的，还有你的皮肤、你的头发，一切。我能对口型说出所有东西。
I know, it's kind of incredible. What the what? All that just spend more time with this group. Yeah, it's true. I just got a call for me, Joe, brother. Yeah. Oh, wait, I have a question. By the way, and aside on that, I've had work situations
我知道，这有点不可思议。什么鬼？所有这些……只是花更多时间跟这个群体在一起。是的，是真的。我刚接到一个电话，乔，兄弟。是的。哦，等一下，我有个问题。顺便说一句，题外话，我曾有过这样的工作情况：
where I guess ironically, given some of the work I've done on sexual harassment the way, and aside on that, I've had work situations where I guess ironically, given some of the work I've done on sexual harassment and stuff, where I'm getting that treatment, like I'm getting objectified, and I'm just not a self-actualized enough person to not get a little, like I'm actually like, you know what, I'm cool with this.
我想具有讽I意味的是，鉴于我做过的一些关于性骚扰之类的事情……顺便说一句，我曾有过这样的工作情况，我想具有讽刺意味的是，鉴于我做过的一些关于性骚扰之类的事情，我正在遭受那种对待，比如我被物化了，而我却没有足够的自我实现能力去不感到一点……就像我其实觉得，“你知道吗，我挺享受这个的。”
I'm telling you more. Like I've gotten so much more validation over the years for just the intellectual stuff. Being a piece of meat is great when it happens. When you get into litigation, let the record show Sean started it. No, to that point, run with the intellectual stuff and all that fuels the fire in your belly and you continue to do all that stimulates that gorgeous brain of yours. What beyond of that excellent work in your life
我跟你说更多。多年来，我因为纯粹的智力方面的东西而得到了更多的肯定。当一块“鲜肉”感觉挺不错的，当它发生的时候。当你卷入诉讼时，请记录在案，肖恩先挑起的。不，说真的，发挥你的智力优势吧，所有这些都能点燃你内心的火焰，并且你会继续做所有能刺激你那个华丽大脑的事。除了生活中那些优秀的工作之外，
excites you. What outside of all this? When are you silly? What do you let it go? All that kind of stuff. Are you a video gamer? Like, what do you do? I am, yeah.
什么还能让你兴奋？除了所有这些之外，什么时候你会犯傻？什么时候你会彻底放松？诸如此类的事情。你玩电子游戏吗？比如，你平时做什么？我是说，我玩的。
So it actually took me a lot of time to understand that that stuff, I mean, this goes back to the broad philosophical conversation, right? That a life that's just about the work. I mean, I missed every major friend's wedding because I was like off interviewing a warlord. That's an actual thing that happened, but I'm so sorry to my friend Jen, who's waiting. I was supposed to sing out and then I miss completely to go interview General Dostum in Afghanistan. Like I made that choice every time.
所以，我其实花了很长时间才明白那些东西，我是说，这可以追溯到广阔的哲学对话，对吧？即一个只关于工作的生命。我是说，我错过了所有好朋友的婚礼，因为我当时正忙着去采访一个军阀。这是真实发生过的事情，我向我的朋友延（Jen）深表歉意，她当时还在等我。我本该去唱歌的，但我完全错过了，跑去阿富汗采访多斯图姆将军了。每次我都做出了那样的选择。
And now I am making the choice to do the fun stuff, to just find joy and yet keep the work going. And I have the work being formed by that. I think if you're kinder to yourself, you can be kinder to others. So yeah, I love being social. I mean, I like going deep with small groups and one on one. But I also love like, I love video games. I love all nerd culture. I
而现在，我正在选择去做有趣的事情，去寻找快乐，同时让工作继续进行。并且让工作受到这些经历的塑造。我认为如果你对自已更仁慈一点，你就能对别人更仁慈。所以，是的，我喜欢社交。我是说，我喜欢和少数人或一对一进行深入交流。但我也喜欢……我喜欢电子游戏。我喜欢所有的书呆子文化。我
love sci-fi. I do too. I love. Oh boy. Here come Sean and Scott. Eat all the time. Are you, are you a gamer? No, not a gamer huge sci-fi. Yeah, Sean and Scotty they have Star Trek night. Yeah, it's Star Wars You would yeah, I'm more I'm more of a Star Wars guy and I really admire the the world view of Star Trek kind of more That it's more about intellectual curiosity, but I haven't taken the time to dig deep. Yeah, hey Let me I haven't seen a lot of it, but let me guess the good guys wouldn't to dig deep. Yeah. Hey, let me, I haven't seen a lot of it, but let me guess the good guys wouldn't. I mean, says the guy with the gravelly voice in the mustache. I want to start with all the, all the old chat and our stuff. I want to like really go back and, and I, I'm on that at some point. Well, we are, we're 16 minutes over here. I apologize, but I could,
喜欢科幻。我也是。我喜欢。哦，天哪。肖恩和斯科特来了。一直在吃。你是……你是游戏玩家吗？不，不是游戏玩家，但我是个超级科幻迷。是的，肖恩和斯科特，他们有《星际迷航》之夜。是的，是《星际大战》。你喜欢……是的，我更倾向于《星际大战》迷，但我真的很欣赏《星际迷航》的那种世界观，它更多的是关于对知识的好奇心，但我没有花时间去深入了解。是的，嘿……让我……我没怎么看过，但让我猜猜，好人不会去深入了解。是的。嘿，让我……我没怎么看过，但让我猜猜，好人不会……我是说，这话出自一个声音低沉沙哑、留着小胡子的家伙之口。我想从所有那些……所有那些老旧的聊天和我们的事情开始。我想真正地回溯过去，而且……我某时会去了解的。好吧，我们超时了16分钟。我很抱歉，但我可以
I could talk to you for a whole day. It's such a great conversation. And I really am sincerely, such a fan of all of yours. I mean, Jason, I remember watching the pilot of Ozark, or I guess it was a series or so, I'm using the term pilot reflexively, the first episode that you directed and my ex turning to me when your name came up
跟你聊上一整天。这是一次非常棒的对话。而且我真的是由衷地成为你们所有人的粉丝。我是说，杰森，我还记得看《黑钱胜地》（Ozark）的试播集，或者我想那是一个系列剧什么的，我下意识地用了“试播集”这个词，也就是你导演的第一集，当你的名字出现在
and the credits and being like, is Jason Bateman one of our great living directors? Is he like one of the best working TV directors? Yes, I can ask. So my name came up and he said, I think he might be. That is, that is. I had to discover that over time,
演职员表时，我的前任转过身来对我说，杰森·贝特曼是我们当今最伟大的导演之一吗？他是目前最好的电视剧导演之一吗？是的，我忍不住问。所以我的名字出现了，他说，我觉得他可能是。那就是……那就是……我后来才发现，
the time that you were that too. And even the- It took a village, thank you. They first uploaded the outside. Or like every time I see you directing something and like, how are you so good at that? Yeah, really kind. Well, yeah, something sinks in after a while and surround yourself with good folks and
你也是那样的人。甚至连……这需要大家的共同努力，谢谢你们。他们第一次上传外部内容时……或者每次我看到你导演什么东西时都会想，你怎么能把这个做得这么好？是的，真的很客气。好吧，是的，有些东西看久了就会潜移默化，而且身边环绕着优秀的人，
there you get it. Yeah. Well, here's to more of that for all of you. And thank you for being so kind in this conversation. Oh, it was so easy. Oh, thank you for joining us. Yeah. So great talking to you in meeting you.
你就能掌握它。好吧，祝你们所有人以后能有更多这样的成就。谢谢你们在这场对话中如此友善。哦，这太轻松了。哦，谢谢你们邀请我们。能和你们谈话并结识你们真是太棒了。
Ronan, thank you. We appreciate you so much for being here. And I hope you pal. Thanks. I hope I get to see on the streets of New York again. Yeah, I hope I get to see you love to meet you in person. Yeah, I'd love that too. All right. Bye, guys.
罗南，谢谢你。非常感谢你能来到这里。我希望你能常来，老兄。谢谢。希望我能在纽约的街头再次见到你。是的，我也希望能在现实生活中见到你。是的，我也很乐意。好了，再见，伙计们。
All right. Enjoy your day. You too. Bye. Thanks, Ronan. Well, another boring prick that just is no charm and doesn't know how to talk what we got to start book and better guests could it get talking to run in Pharaoh yeah just kept talking to that I mean real sweet on that fella handsome it tastes smart a man doesn't a lot of trouble
好的。祝你们今天过得愉快。你也是。再见。谢谢你，罗南。又是一个无聊的讨厌鬼，一点魅力都没有，也不知道怎么聊天，我们得开始预订更好的嘉宾了，怎么能跟罗南·费罗聊呢？是的，一直在跟他聊。我是说，对那个家伙真的很温柔，又帅又有品味，还很聪明，这人惹上的麻烦可不少。
okay she's in a lot of trouble why it's alright why I just found myself really enjoying his company? Okay. Uh-oh. Uh-oh. No, it's that say, uh, that's, that's a, that's a real interesting fella right there. Yeah, I agree. Um, I cannot believe the guy went to college at 11. When you said, are you kidding? And I, I almost said like, what's he fucking kidding shot with?
好吧，她惹上了大麻烦。为什么？这很好啊。为什么？我发现自己真的很享受他的陪伴。好吧。噢哦。噢哦。不，我是说，那……那是一个非常有趣的家伙。是的，我同意。呃，我真不敢相信这家伙11岁就上大学了。当你这么说的时候，你在开玩笑吗？我差点就要说……肖恩是在瞎扯什么呢？
Wait, he's not kidding. Not kidding. 11. I know. I know. 11 years old and barred 15 at Yale. I mean, incredible. He's not getting. Not kidding. 11. I know. 11 years old. He's getting barred 15 at Yale. I mean, incredible. He's had Lord. You imagine. Hey, guys, anybody going to the, you know, front party like 15 years old? Yeah. Well, good for him. And, uh,
等等，他不是在开玩笑。不是开玩笑。11岁。我知道。我知道。11岁，15岁在耶鲁大学过关斩将。我是说，太不可思议了。他不是在开玩笑。不是开玩笑。11岁。我知道。11岁。15岁在耶鲁大学过关斩将。我是说，太不可思议了。我的天呐。你能想象吗？嘿，伙计们，有人要去大约15岁的那场前线派对吗？是的。好吧，祝他好运。而且，呃，
Sean, I didn't know you did impressions. That was, yeah, that's fantastic. Hey, guys, I'm going to the front party. Hey, what's the big idea? I'm going to bust this joint out. You said, you guys are about 30s filled. I want to have a sandwich. Now, Willie, you're there. You're there in Atlanta. I see you're in. Yeah. And be sure to hang out of your sales receipt. What do you got the rest of the day out there, Willie? Well, we got another record later on. We do. I got some hockey later on after I've already been to the gym.
肖恩，我不知道你还会模仿别人。那真是……太棒了。嘿，伙计们，我要去前线派对。嘿，这是什么主意？我要把这地方砸了。你说，你们大概30岁左右。我想吃个三明治。现在，威利，你在那儿。你在亚特兰大。我看到你在……是的。别忘了拿好你的销售收据。威利，今天剩下的时间你有什么安排？好吧，我们稍后还有一场录音。是的。我待会儿去完健身房后还要打曲棍球。
Really sorry about the King's waxing your dumb ass maple leaves the other day. It's leaves you fucking dick. What did I say? I say leaves the leaves. It's plural. He was doing plural. All the players are the leaves. Yeah, plural. He was doing plural. All the players are the leaves. Yeah, exactly.
对于国王队前几天把你们愚蠢的枫叶队打得落花流水，我深表遗憾。是“叶子”（Leaves），你个混蛋！我刚才说什么了？我说的是“叶子”（leaves）。这是复数形式。他用的是复数。所有队员都是叶子。对，复数。他用的是复数。所有的队员都是叶子。对，没错。
That is the plural, okay? And it was a bit of a battalion in the Canadian Army, World War I, Maple Leaf Battalion. So if you have a consmite named in the Maple Leafs. So if you had a bunch of Maple Leafs exiting the team bus, how would you write that? LEA-F apostrophe S? No. Or no, you wouldn't use the apostrophe. You just have the S.
那是复数，好吧？那是加拿大军队在一战中的一个营，枫叶营（Maple Leaf Battalion）。所以如果你有一支以枫叶命名的球队……所以如果你有一群枫叶队球员正从球队大巴上下来，你会怎么拼写？L-E-A-F撇号S？不对。或者说，你不会用撇号。你只会加个S。
Yeah. Would it be Leaves or would it be V or F? Leaves. Leaves. With what letters? Yes. No, with an F for a V. F-F.
是的。应该是Leaves（叶子的复数）还是V还是F？Leaves。叶子（Leaves）。用什么字母？是的。不对，是用F还是V？F。
Huh. I don't know if that's correct. It says it on the jersey. I think they spelled it wrong. Well, that's because it's plural. If you had like three. and it's a proper name, it's a proper name. It's the, they created it, they created a name.
嗯。我不知道这是否正确。球衣上就是这么写的。我觉得他们拼错了。好吧，那是因为它是复数。如果你有三个……而且这是一个专有名词，这是一个专有名词。这是他们创造的，他们创造了一个名字。
Yeah. But if you had like three of something you'd call it try, and if you had two of something, you would call it, bye, bye. Also, if you went both ways. Smart. Smart. Smart.
是的。但如果你有三个某种东西，你会称之为“三（try）”，如果你有两个某种东西，你会称之为“双（bi）”。另外，如果你两边都行的话……聪明。聪明。聪明。
Smart. Also, if you went both ways. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Smiles. Flies. Smiles. Smiles is 100% organic and artistically handcrafted by Rob Armjurff, Bennett Barbaco, and Michael Grandtary. Smiles. Flies. Bennett Barbaco and Michael Granterry.
聪明。另外，如果你两边都行的话……微小（Smiles）。微小（Smiles）。微小（Smiles）。微小（Smiles）。微小（Smiles）。微小（Smiles）。苍蝇（Flies）。微小（Smiles）。《微小》（Smiles）是100%有机制作，由罗布·阿姆朱夫（Rob Armjuff）、贝内特·巴尔巴科（Bennett Barbaco）和迈克尔·格兰特里（Michael Granterry）进行艺术化手工打造的。微小（Smiles）。苍蝇（Flies）。贝内特·巴尔巴科和迈克尔·格兰特里。
Smart loss. in Apple Podcasts or the Wondry app. Hi, it's me, the Grand Poova of Bahambad, the OG Green Grump, the Grinch. From Wondery! Tis the Grinch holiday talk show is a pathetic attempt by the people of O'Vill to use my situation as a teachable moment. So join me, the Grinch, along with Cindy Lohu. Hello, everyone. And of course course my dog Max every week for
在 Apple Podcasts 或 Wondry App 上收看《SmartLess》。嗨，是我，轰巴得的总普瓦，绿色老脾气，圣诞怪杰（The Grinch）。来自 Wondry！《圣诞怪杰节日脱口秀》（Tis the Grinch Holiday Talk Show）是胡村（O'Vill）人民可悲的企图，他们想利用我的处境作为一个有教育意义的时刻。所以加入我，圣诞怪杰，还有辛迪·露·胡（Cindy Lohu）。大家好。当然还有我的狗马克斯，每周收看
this complete waste of time. Listen as I launch a campaign against Christmas cheer, grilling celebrity guests, like chestnuts on an open fire. Now try to get my heart to grow a few sizes, but it's not gonna work, honey. Your family will love the show. As you know, I'm famously great with kids. Follow Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show on the Wondery app or wherever you get your podcasts. You can listen to Tiz the Grinch Holiday Talk Show early and add free right now by joining
这个完全浪费时间的节目。听我发起一场反对圣诞欢乐的运动，像在明火上烤栗子一样拷问名人嘉宾。现在试着让我的心长粗几号，但这不会起作用的，亲爱的。你的家人会喜欢这个节目的。如你所知，我对小孩子向来是出了名的好。在 Wondry App 或你获取播客的任何地方关注《圣诞怪杰节日脱口秀》。你现在就可以加入
Wondery Plus. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Wondry Plus，提前且无广告收听《圣诞怪杰节日脱口秀》。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可留下评论。